Hello everybody!
Welcome back to Metal Gear Saturdays!
Yippee!
Hello, hello, hello, Min-to.
Hello, hello.
Hey, big boss.
No.
Just boss.
Oh, hi, I'm Minto.
I just came back from an all-night idol life.
Go to sleep?
What are you doing?
Music's so creepy.
I love being called Ojo-sama by Minto.
You are my Ojo-sama.
Or Go Shijin-sama.
Could be both.
I don't know.
Pick one.
Go!
Thanks for the five gift.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So.
metal gear um i don't know i'm i'm kind of blocking it but
it says like on the bottom right it says like w s as if i'm
not playing on a controller day two ago i bought the
collection and played through mgs1 but couldn't beat the
final too much trolling what do you mean too much trolling
it couldn't beat rex i believe in you if i can do it you can
do it unless you mean no But, no.
Probably the chase.
I was going to say, unless you mean the chase segment.
No.
Well, today, so I was, initially, it was just like, I'm
going to play super duper long.
If I beat the game, cool.
If I don't, we'll save it for another day.
But I wanted to get close.
But now I'm thinking.
Um, I was thinking, I was like, oh man, I have a concert
next week.
I should probably not be doing super duper duper long
streams, just so I can protect my voice a little bit.
I'm Dragon Ball 6 for that 20 gift card.
Happy Canada Day.
Oh, Canada.
So, um, not to say that I won't go long, um, but I'm
thinking, I don't know.
we'll go we'll just we'll just go and when i feel like it's
an appropriate time i'm thinking maybe like before vulcan
raven because then once i get to vulcan raven i think that's
like a decent point after him to be able to beat the game
maybe i don't know maybe go ahead thanks for the vibe gifted
thank you so we'll see we'll see how far i get how well i do
on some of these on some of these bosses and um yeah so uh
yeah we'll just see i'll just i'll just play and have a good
time and hopefully you guys have a good time too talkers oh
thanks for the five gifted thank you
well last time.
I hope so.
I want to go through the entire Metal Gear series.
Which games do I play after the first three?
Four!
One, two, three, four, Peace Walker, Ground Zeroes, five.
If you're starting from there.
Yeah.
Pyrobug!
Thanks for that time!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
aren't sure.
We stopped right before Psycho Mantis.
So we will be starting the stream with Psycho Mantis.
And I am playing on Integral.
Well done!
Thanks for the bye!
Ready for her to scream.
Stop it.
No.
No, I have to protect my voice.
I have to protect my voice for the concert next week.
Secomintus.
Yeah, Secomintus.
I'm playing on Integral.
But it's in English, don't worry.
Oh, maybe I should make myself a little smaller.
Like that?
There we go.
My sleeve is a little large and in charge.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys for all the super chats.
I remember this coming out and using my chore money to buy
it.
Oh my gosh, I remember having to use my chore money to buy
games too.
Before I forget, I was surprised to see a Ayami-sensei's
panel at Asen.
Yeah!
Hope the spicy snacks didn't cook your gut.
Do you think Ayami would be interested in playing the Metal
Gear series?
No.
Ayami-sensei's not really...
She doesn't really play games.
If I tell her to play something, she's like, I don't really
play video games.
You know what?
That's okay.
Dog strings, thanks to the five giftings.
Welcome back.
We can watch this just to...
An Alaska's Fox Archipelago.
Archipelago.
How would a Balenciaga mint Metal Gear Fest?
Balenciaga!
I don't even know what Balenciaga looks like.
They're demanding that the government turn over the remains
of Big Boss.
And they say that if their demands are not met within 24
hours, they'll launch a nuclear weapon.
I will change the subtitles.
They will be in English, so don't you worry.
You'll have two mission objectives.
First, you're to rescue DARPA chief Donald Anderson.
And the president of Armistek, Kenneth Baker.
Kenneth Baker.
Terrorist though.
Kenny!
How's the audio?
a one-man SDV.
Kenneth Baca.
After the SDV gets as close as it can.
They smell like a Baca.
They're on, you'll have to swim.
Kenneth Baker.
Is that it?
Okay.
I'm inserting.
Oh, Foxhound.
Your former unit.
And one that I was a commander of.
Oh, I also want to say...
Here, I'll type it.
in this terrorist activity.
Psycho Mattis, with his powerful psychic abilities.
Sniper Wolf, a beautiful and deadly sharpshooter.
No spoilers?
Not for me, but for anyone who may have not played the
series before.
Thank you.
Wee-wee!
I love that guy!
And a formidable gunfighter.
And finally, in charge of them, Foxhound Squad Leader.
Giant and Shamer.
You play the OG games on String?
Yeah, probably.
I've played them before.
The nuclear weapons disposal facility covers the whole
island.
I'll instruct you by Kodak after you reach your target.
Anyone going with me?
Nope.
Sneaking mission.
Duh.
This is a top secret black op.
Don't expect any official support.
Oh man.
I need support.
At least I have Master Miller.
NES version?
Sure.
Metal Gear Solid Integral!
Oh my god, Muscle Bunchy!
Thank you so much for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
So, um, let me make sure that the subtitles and stuff are in
English.
Caption on.
Vibration on, baby, on, baby.
Okay.
That should be good.
Wait, did it save?
Hold on, sorry.
Okay, good, good, good, good, good, good.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right, so we're right before...
Right before Psychobiontus.
The nuclear building basement one.
What is this one?
Oh, did I only do two saves?
Read mission log?
No, I think we're good.
But I do like seeing the art.
Can't believe Mint isn't playing in the optimal order of
four, survive, one rising, three, five, and then peaceful.
I know, right?
Blasphemy.
okay let's go I know this place better than you I'll be
point man follow me okay good so that left us off right here
we got to do the whole cut scene with Meryl that's me in the
mirror man in the mirror I don't know how that song goes
just go look at her pants one more time oh yeah baby oh
Well, they probably smell like Soldier, huh?
That's strange.
There's no guard.
And no music.
What happened to the music?
I'll keep a lookout.
Make sure you're ready, okay?
Why do you have to say it like that, Meryl?
Why do you have to say it like that, huh?
What?
What is it?
What if I get really close to her?
Wow, every pixel is visible.
What are you staring at?
She's getting red.
Get red.
Come on, Snake.
Get as red as your hair.
Wow, the pixels.
Don't stare at me like that.
Am I making you embarrassed?
What are you doing?
We've got to get a move on.
being so silly look at all those pixels yeah what what is it
get red become a tomato what are you staring at just you
know your tomato body all right let's see now I know that
there's I can't go in there but I can grab the dizazepam And
the night vision goggles.
And um...
And uh...
Man, I sure love them torpedoes.
So calm.
Is this a ration?
I'm full on ration?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Let's get all these things, all these goodies.
Stun grenade.
Nope.
We're good.
That one.
Oh, I can't go in here.
Carboard box B!
Nice.
Okay, guys.
Oh.
Yes?
Oh, what?
Wait, why is she running here?
Hello?
Come on, Snake.
Why'd you come in here?
What?
Look how red she is still.
She heard you scream.
Don't stare at me like that.
Okay, let's go fight a guy.
Oh, gosh.
Sparrow, I have to pee first.
Okay.
You ready?
I like the way she like...
Wait, did you turn unred?
No, I think it's just the lighting.
Okay.
I'm like, I'm nervous!
I'm nervous!
Psycho Mantis was really hard for me before, so I'm nervous.
Oh gosh, here we go.
I don't remember his patterning, like his patterns at all.
Oh, I don't have...
Wait, I don't have full health.
Maybe I should go get the ration.
Snake, what are you doing?
Let's go to the commander's room.
But Meryl, my health!
Meryl, please, understand, Meryl.
Meryl.
Oh, no, I'm not at full health.
It's okay.
I could always reload.
I recall.
Oh, yeah.
Ouch, ouch.
It hurts.
What's wrong?
Don't come here, Snake.
I love it.
this part.
Ah.
What happened?
Snake is not doing any.
You good?
I'm fine.
Okay.
Let's go.
I love this part.
Say the line.
Come on, Mr. Foxhound.
A commander is waiting.
Yeah!
I love that line.
so much it's so cool come on mr.
Foxhound the commander is waiting oh boy oh boy oh golly
don't shoot snake how do you like me What the?
What the?
Do you like me?
Hold me.
Snake.
What's wrong?
Oh, hurry.
Make love to me.
Oh, Snake.
I want you.
What is that?
I don't like girls.
You don't like girls.
Merrill's not herself.
Don't use your weapon.
It's Psycho Man.
Mantis.
He's controlling Meryl.
That tune is his mind control music.
Why am I okay then?
Don't use your weapon.
Try to knock her out.
Okay.
I'll knock her out.
Come on, Meryl.
Get it together.
Get it together, Meryl.
Meryl.
Meryl, get it together.
Dueless woman.
say camouflage huh i hope that's not your only trick i mean
this man is floating snake what are you talking about you
doubt my power this guy is floating in bit air now i will
show you why i am the most powerful practitioner of
psychokinesis and telepathy in the world in the world no
there's no need for words snake yeah i am the psycho mantis
yippee that's right this is is no trick it's true power i
can hear the mechanics of like the wiring holding him up in
the ceiling your every fault now let me read your mind no
perhaps i should say your past you are a very methodical man
the type that always kicks his tires before he leaves I'm a
highly skilled warrior, well-suiting to this- Whoa!
Stop!
Are you kidding me?
You are extremely skilled warrior!
I'm a highly skilled warrior!
Oh, I'm a coward?
That's okay too.
Oh my god!
Now I'll read more deeply into your soul.
I'm a gamer.
Ah, I can see into your mind.
What games do I like?
So, you like Sui Kong.
then you like Castlevania don't you I like Castlevania you
enjoy role-playing games so you like adventure game I see
that you enjoy Konami games we you have not saved often I
haven't you are somewhat reckless oh I I can read you like
an open book.
You still don't believe me?
I will show you how to save scum in a little bit.
Put your controller on the floor.
Okay, I put it on my desk.
Put it down as fast as you can.
Yep, hold on.
That's good.
Oh, here.
I'll put it here.
Now I will move your controller.
I'll put it on my desk.
Hopefully you guys can hear it.
There it goes.
Oh, my power now.
Oh my god, it's moving!
Demonstration is over.
Oh, okay.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, God.
Oh, God!
Hideo!
Alright.
Master Miller.
Help me.
It's true.
Your enemy is a powerful telepath.
But you've got more battle experience.
I do.
You can do it, Snake.
Oh my gosh.
He's so nice.
I love you.
Oh, that's real.
That's Psycho Mantis, former KGB psychic.
His powerful telepathic abilities.
After the collapse of the Soviet Union, he came to America
looking for a job.
He worked with the FBI on several cases as a psychic
profiler.
Five years ago, he was working on the case of a multiple
serial murderer.
He got too far into the killer's mind.
As a result, he became just like the killer.
So he was sort of infected by the serial murderer's
thoughts.
In any case, after that, he became a sort of psychic spy,
working for the highest bidder.
He traveled all around the world.
I love how that's when he was recruited.
This is all kind of retcon.
He can read people's minds.
He knows every move that you're going to make.
What should I do?
I've got no chance of beating him.
There must be some way.
He's a master at controlling people, Snake.
Don't let him manipulate you.
No Streamlabs notice?
They're probably blocked or backed up behind a bunch of
gifted...
memberships so i see your note of or i see your donation
paul thank you colonel in which slot does the credit card go
thank you so much your plan wait the order you're playing
seems fine wait what do you wait okay here we go um i don't
feel like i need to save justasha what do you have to say
it's like a soldier yes although they I can't hear you over
the music.
Nostasia.
Speak up.
Ben's spoons?
Merrill's on the ground.
Deep throw.
We know he was not going to respond.
Okay.
hold on guys i'm so sorry oh but also we're just gonna
controller connection connect as p2 p has come to and yes
i'm blind i know me too here we go oh gosh i can't see oh
God, this is worse than anything!
This is so bad.
Oh my gosh, it's so hard to see.
And
green.
Oh, this is, uh...
Okay, um, crouch.
I can't...
Oh, God, I can't do this, you guys.
I can't do this.
Oh my God, it's so impossible to see.
Oh, okay.
Ooh, that was close.
What?
What just hit me?
Are you kidding me right now?
What?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, okay.
So laying down.
Wait a second.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I don't...
Uh-oh.
This is bad.
Eek!
He's not even...
He'll
hurt me even when I'm laying down.
Okay, that's good to know.
Oh my gosh.
The chairs are poisonous.
What?
Okay, oh my gosh.
Where are you?
Get him!
Oh!
Okay, you guys, this is not good.
I thought that the chairs couldn't get me if I laid down.
Clearly that's not the case.
The poisonous chairs.
Can I still shoot him from here?
Oh.
Oh, I can grab that ration.
Ouch!
Oh, grab that ration now.
I can't reach.
Oh, that was close.
Oh, get him.
Get his butt!
I can hear him.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
I got him.
Okay, nice, nice.
I can't remember, though.
His patterns at all.
Okay, now he throws the ball, right?
Ow!
I ran right into it.
Don't laugh at me.
Don't laugh at me, Psycho Mantis, please.
I'm embarrassed.
Get him.
Get his fight!
Get his fight in front of you.
Okay.
Now I hide over here.
I can get him from here, though, right?
Oh.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Maybe I can't.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh!
These guys...
These guys are the Bainomar existence!
Wow!
Run away!
Get this butt!
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness.
Get him!
I think he was over here?
Oh!
I need to see you.
disappeared and he's gonna throw a thing at me oh I'm out oh
my god I'm out of bullets I'm out of bullets
why no famus I don't know he's gonna throw a thing
hey chairs I can't reach can I still get him
I'm just shooting into the...
Shooting into the...
Ouch!
You dang statue!
Get his ass!
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay, that's the...
Okay.
Ah!
Get his ass!
Oh my goodness.
What the heck is this?
Look at those start flying too.
Okay.
Where'd he go?
He's on this side.
Stop it, Meryl.
You're not yourself when you're hungry.
Ow!
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
No!
Ah!
Come on, that was so cheap.
I don't even know.
Oh, I got more so gone.
Seriously, I don't know about this.
Oh, shit.
Oh, come on.
I'm literally running right into them.
Why are you shooting so slowly, Snake?
Oh.
I gotta get him.
Ah!
Please!
Stick, run!
Why isn't it shooting fast?
Oh, that was close.
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Oh no!
Oh, you guys, this might be the first one that I have to
redo.
This might be the first one I have to redo.
Turn around.
No!
The chairs!
Ah!
Where is he?
I'm just gonna shoot.
I'm gonna shoot.
I'll get you somehow!
Mantis!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Oh, I hate those little guys.
I hate them so much.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please!
Shut up!
Colonel, your niece is going to be okay.
Thanks, Snake.
I owe you one.
Now that Mantis has beaten, Meryl's brainwashing should wear
off, right Naomi?
When it's being a dream, for real.
Why did you go so far out of your way to save her?
For Campbell's sake, or maybe it's because you like her?
I don't want to see any woman die right in front of me.
Oh, really?
Since when did anybody's death bother you so much?
Shut up, Naomi.
You're so dramatic.
It's true that Snake has killed a lot of people.
That doesn't mean he doesn't have a heart.
It's okay, Colonel.
First try?
Easy!
I know!
Actually!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Maybe I have improved as a gamer.
You used the other...
I wasn't able to read the future.
The strong man doesn't need to read the future.
He makes his own.
Perhaps so.
But I'll read you.
Show her future.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Showing her skills as a soldier.
As a gamer.
That's why he said I was a skilled soldier.
To Metal Gear's underground maintenance base.
You have to go through that hidden door.
There's a hidden door behind the bookcase.
The overland route.
It's blocked by frozen glaciers.
Go past the communication towers and use the tower's
walkway.
You know what fight I always forget about in this game is
the Hindee.
Why are you telling me this?
I always forget about it.
I can read people's minds.
In my lifetime, I have read the past, presence, and futures
of thousands upon thousands of men and women.
Ugh, gross.
Oh, gross.
and each mind that I peered into was stuffed with the same
single object of obsession that selfish and atavistic desire
to pass on one seed it was enough to make me sick it's a big
one every living thing on this planet exists to mindlessly
pass on their DNA we're designed that way and that's why
there is war but you you were different i'm not like other
i'm not like other soldiers you're the same as us we have no
past no future we live in the moment that's our only purpose
humans weren't designed to bring each other happiness from
the moment we're thrown into this world we're fated to bring
each other nothing but pain and misery you're wrong the
first person whose mind I dove into was my father's I saw
nothing but disgust and hatred for me in his heart my mother
died in childbirth and he despised me for it I thought my
father was going to kill me
That's when my future I think she needs to be done
Disappeared I lost my past as well Just say everything on
Fire, baby Fire Are you saying that you burned your village
down to bury your past I see that you have suffered the same
trauma Ew Sounds like me when I Gross last truly the same
you and I the world is a more interesting place with people
like you we're not like you psycho mantis I never agreed
with the boss's revolution his dreams of world conquest do
not interest me I just wanted an excuse to kill as many
people as I caught you you're a weirdo you monster let him
talk he doesn't have much time left yeah i've seen through
evil you snake you're just like the boss let him cook are
you worse compared to you i'm not so bad this guy sucks so
much poor snake he doesn't deserve it he doesn't deserve
this well marils he matched my freak saw you there oh you
have a large place in your heart a large place a large place
yes a large place but I do not know if your futures lie
together I have a last request what is it my mask put it
back on okay like this other people's thoughts Force their
way into my mind Before I die Want to be by myself.
I want to be left alone in my own world He's like reach for
it.
He's like lift your head buddy Reach for it.
I know you're dying
This is the first time I've ever used my power to help
someone it's strange it feels kind of nice no life
no bullets you knocked the heck out of Merrill let's go
Merrill thank you I'm sorry Merrill how could I let Mantis
control my mind like that I know how embarrassing if you're
gonna doubt yourself.
I'll leave you here You're right Never doubt yourself.
Just let it make you stronger learn something from it.
You're right I'm sorry.
I won't do it again The mirror being smashed.
It's so sad.
Snake can I ask you something?
What right about what Mantis said?
I was just wondering what what's the problem now?
I think what I think the way snake acts here so tell me
snake i think what mantis said really got to him you know
your real name a name means nothing on the battlefield he's
just like yeah i am old enough to know what death looks like
weapon any family no but i was raised by many people yeah is
there anyone you like i've never been interested in anyone
else's life so you are all alone just like mantis said
just complicate my life.
Say what you're thinking, Meryl.
I don't like to get involved.
Be honest.
You're a sad, lonely man.
Dang, not that honest.
Let's go.
Yay!
Defeat Psycho Mantis.
Oh, oh, it's saying to change it back to Controller 1.
Thank you, game.
Wait, yes, it's P1.
There we go.
Okay.
Um, okay, so I've basically exhausted all of my materials
here.
Can I?
Oh, Seiko Mantis.
Oh!
Kiss!
Wait, how do I get that angle again?
Wow!
Myoshi's a pro gamer!
Thank you!
Um, can I go back now?
Oh, that's not the door.
What are you doing?
We've got to get a move on.
Merrill, there was rations back there.
Merrill, you don't understand!
I have...
Oh, I have 29 bullets.
I have 12 bullets!
This is bad.
It's fine, though.
We're fine, probably.
I know there's a ration in here, isn't there?
Or there's stuff.
Yeah, okay.
We got a little bit at least.
there we go oh and then more bullets oh there be wolves in
there wolf dogs half wolf half husky how do you know so I
almost said I'm a musher I love I'll take point snake you
follow me okay don't leave me behind though Merrill that
That would be really rude of you, okay?
Girlie?
Don't leave me behind.
I believe you went this way.
It would be really, really, really rude of you.
Nice.
Oh, oh.
You bitch!
Oh.
Oh, there's more stuff down there too.
I never realized.
Thank you.
I'll take all that I can get right now.
Oh.
I don't want to kill the dogs, but...
I could stun the dogs.
But I only have three.
We shouldn't waste them.
What's that sound?
The pups?
The dogs walking around?
See?
Look, it's a dog.
That's a full...
That's a wolf dog.
That's a full wolf dog.
They won't, will they bother me if I'm in the box?
I can't remember.
Oh!
Little pup.
Mushin makes me feel good.
I can't remember if they bother me in the box.
I do.
It's so hard to see in here.
I'm just afraid I'm gonna get lost.
I gotta get peed on first.
Oh no.
Inconvenienced.
What do you mean inconvenience?
It's more like death!
What are you talking about?
Oh, actually, let's call people.
Let's see what Campbell says.
Be careful.
Wolves have the advantage in the dark.
Not only can they see better, but they have a keen sense of
smell as well.
You'd better use your night vision goggles.
Oh.
Okay.
I'll only use it because Campbell told me to.
You know, the Colonel.
don't suddenly look into the dark look slowly from a light
area to a darker area if you do that your eyes will
gradually adjust and you'll be able to see better in the
dark try not to play in the dark either don't play in the
dark everybody snake you sold a ton radar i know i can't use
it in the narrow space like this right right i'm sorry no
reason to apologize Even the greatest masterpiece has its
flaws.
We'll save.
Actually, no.
I'll do a new one.
Even though I don't want to go back and defeat Mantis again.
True Brain Rod is casually saying I gotta get Piedon first.
Like, that's a natural part of game progression.
But it is!
Me Ling, how did you get into this line of work?
Yeah, the truth is, I always wanted to become a fighter
pilot.
I fell in love with jets watching them in the movie.
She's so cool.
You'd be surprised how many people say the same thing.
No.
But I didn't want to kill people.
That's when I heard that the U.S.
Air Force needed people to do BDAs, battle damage
assessments.
Those are the guys whose job it is to confirm how successful
a bombing run was.
Yeah, so I started to do research into aerial photography
and air intelligence.
I made it my major.
But there are no pilots who only do BDAs.
That's right.
But by the time I learned that, I was already an expert in
my field.
She's so smart.
I love it.
Just casually.
Isn't she like 16 or 17?
She's like, yeah, I was going to become a fighter, like a,
you know, a pilot.
I was going to...
At her age.
Merrill, can you come pick me up?
I hate her.
Okay, anyway.
Gah!
Ugh!
Okay, there's no dogs here.
Oh,
he's gone.
Oh, I'm trying to fight a dog.
Hold on.
Oh, no!
No, don't!
Don't eat me!
Is it this way?
I must punch- I must punch the dogs!
I must punch the dogs!
punch the punch punch punch punch punch punch punch punch
punch punch oh shoot where's the area i'm gonna die here
because of dogs punch the dog punch the dog punch punch
punch punch punch punch punch punch punch punch punch punch
punch don't even oh
punch punch punch punch punch punch punch
actually ideal scenario.
This is the ideal scenario, you guys.
Punch,
punch, punch, punch, punch.
it here?
No, it's not.
Oh, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch.
Get up, get up, snake.
Punch, punch, punch, punch.
Oh my god.
You guys are in danger.
Where is the entrance?
Oh, I somehow... Go, snake, go.
Oh, I'm safe.
I'm safe.
Oh my god.
Wait, this isn't it, is it?
I got a ration, though.
I can never find this damn exit.
That is a Oh,
they knocked me into the cave with the wrong one.
There's just a baby looking at me.
Okay, wait, this other guy needs to go.
Oh, hey, hey.
Okay, I think we can go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Are you kidding me?
I hate you.
I hate you, little dog.
Stay go!
Please, please stay go!
Ah, ah, okay, okay.
Oh.
This is so messed up.
I thought the- Snake, what's wrong?
Yeah.
I thought so too.
This is so messed up.
Meryl, they took all my rations!
They robbed me!
They robbed me blind.
Come on.
Give me piss immunity, please.
What do I do?
Have to hit her, right?
Yippee!
Unball!
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
What are you thinking?
I'm using my brain for real.
Okay.
Anyway.
We're all good.
Kind of.
Could be better, honestly.
Anyway, let's just go.
It's box A.
This place is mine.
I'll take point again.
Uh-oh.
Stay back, okay?
Wait.
The radar is working.
And since we can't use the mine detector either...
My mom is calling me.
Mom, stop calling me.
She actually wanted me to come see her today.
But...
Oh, I gotta pay attention.
Oh.
I'm just gonna crawl.
So, what do you think?
Pretty good, huh?
Pretty good.
How did you know where the mines were?
It sounds weird, but when Mantis dove into my mind, I was
able to see where the mines were placed.
Then Hank can run straight to her?
Are you impressed?
You can, but I always managed to mess it up anyway.
Only a little?
Just run straight up.
I always managed to get them anyway.
It's okay, though.
We'll just crawl and collect them all.
Is that all of them?
Wee!
I think that's all of them.
Right?
I think so.
Probably.
Spee?
Spee!
Whoa!
Whoa, Merrill, they turned me into a baby!
Blade!
Okay, I think we're good.
Anyway, don't get shot, Merrill.
Merrill, what is it?
Oh.
Merrill, get down!
Merrill!
We said get down, Merrill!
Ah!
Oh my goodness.
Girl.
Oh!
Ah!
Snake, leave me and run.
Meryl.
I am a rookie after all.
Don't worry, Meryl.
It's me they want.
Even I know that.
It's the oldest trick in the book.
Yeah, pretty much.
Trying to lure you out.
Sniper used me for bait to lure you out.
Damn.
Shoot me, Snake.
No.
My gun.
I can't reach it by myself.
Don't move.
I promised.
I wouldn't slow you down.
I-I-I can still help.
I want to help you.
Quiet down.
Save your strength.
I was a fool.
I wanted to be a soldier.
But war is ugly.
There's nothing glamorous about it.
Snake, please save yourself.
Go on living and don't give up on people.
Don't forget me.
I like this part a lot.
Now get out of here.
Merrill.
Damn.
Snake, it's a trap.
I like the ring when it's like all quiet.
The sniper's waiting for you to go and help Merrill.
And like Snake just being like, what do I do?
What do I do?
Don't do it.
Must be Sniper Wolf.
Foxhound's best shooter.
Sniper's usually work in pairs, but this one's alone, huh?
I know her.
She can wait for hours, days, or weeks.
It doesn't matter to her.
She's just watching and waiting for you to expose yourself.
Maybe so, but Meryl can't hold out that long.
Snake, can you see Wolf from where you are?
There's nowhere to hide between here and the tower.
She must be on the second floor of the tower.
If Wolf is in the communications tower, she can see you
perfectly.
It's the classic sniper's position.
At that distance, you won't be able to hit her with a
standard weapon either.
You'll need a sniper rifle.
Colonel, take it easy.
Take it easy.
I'm going to save Merrill, no matter what it takes.
Okay.
Thanks.
What's wrong, Naomi?
Nothing.
I'm just surprised you're willing to sacrifice yourself.
You got the genes of a soldier not to save him.
Oh my God, Naomi, please!
I'm trying to save him.
Oh my god!
I wouldn't go that far, but...
I don't know what the hell my genes look like and I don't
care.
Yeah!
Operate on instinct.
Like an animal.
Oh my god.
I'm going to save Merrill.
I don't need an excuse.
She's so rude!
And I'm not doing it for someone else either.
I'm gonna save Merrill for myself.
You're so rude, Naomi.
Don't worry.
Snake.
Thanks.
I understand.
I'm sorry.
Ugh.
Okay, um...
Let's leave...
Bye!
Hokey-dokey.
Was there any other...
What's it called around here?
Any other places I can...
Excuse me?
What was that?
You can leave.
you can leave now you can leave i think if i get attacked by
this dog without a ration on i will actually die so um oh my
god please go away
yeah let's go back to meryl real quick um That was really
intense.
How are you so good at that?
Okie dokie.
Let's go through first.
Surely the dogs are gone.
Okay.
Let's go through first.
Oh, shoot.
Box.
Okay.
Oh, stealth is...
is optional in this game, you guys.
Stealth is optional.
Is it...
I don't actually know where the part or the area is.
Well, we got some bullets.
I'll take that.
Okay, thank you, little poppies.
Thank you.
I know you love me so much.
I know.
I'm so cool.
I'm so kakoi.
I know.
You just really love me.
Okay, bye.
Come on.
Okie dokie.
We have to go all the way back, baby, to go get that PSG,
which I can't remember exactly where it was at.
I know it's in the second.
It's in the basement.
Oh, thank goodness.
Thank you.
game you're so kind game you're so game oh game oh game
sometimes you're so cruel and sometimes you're so kind ask
Otacon you're so right wait oh shoot what was Otacon's
frequency we haven't even called him once wait what was
Otacon's frequency stay out of her range and shoot at her
with a sniper rifle yeah but where can I I can't ask one for
one one two.
Okay.
He's been on the base for a while.
He might know
Stay out of a range and yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Oh, there we go.
Hi Otacon.
I was thinking that I was missing someone.
Have you ever seen a sniper rifle anywhere on this base?
A sniper rifle?
Merrill's been shot.
It is in the it's where I didn't have to go before but a
high quality sniper rifle is the way I could fight back I
hear I saw a PSG-1 in the armory in the second floor
basement of the tank hangar the second floor basement of the
tank hangar I have to go all the way back there well yeah
what's wrong with you Otakon hmm nothing nothing eh yeah you
want to elaborate buddy Otakon thank you hmm master you need
to make decisions in war the difference between living and
dying is counted in milliseconds milliseconds okay i don't
think there's anything else in here nope oh my gosh i keep
thinking i keep getting their door wrong
that guy is just peeing away
Alright.
Let's go to...
All the way back.
I'm also a box.
So glad nobody has to use this elevator!
I am also a box.
Yep.
We'll just wait for this guy to walk on by.
I'm not even gonna deal with them I'm just gonna go we're
gonna wait now the field has oh shoot wait now the field has
cameras doesn't it should I take the should I try for the
okay one mailing I'm gonna say same save what can I do for
you snake am I going to maybe Maybe I'll try and take the
truck.
In China, they say.
Roshness brings success to few.
Misfortune to many.
Is she telling me not to take the truck?
Go forward when it's safe.
But retreat when there's danger.
You'll just have to play it by ear depending on the
circumstances.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Yeah.
Tell where the other guy is.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
That was a camera.
He should be coming around any second.
I feel...
I'm trying to look.
There we go.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Okay, don't move, don't move, don't move.
Don't move, he's gonna notice me, but he's gonna say just a
box.
He's gonna go, huh, just a box.
You didn't even notice me!
What a dummy!
Oh my gosh, you're an idiot!
You're a dummy for real!
Okay, it's kind of tight here.
Never mind.
Not nearly as tight as I thought it was.
Just a box.
Okay, cool.
This is the right one, right?
Yeah, heliport.
Cool.
Just a box.
Stinky.
Smelly.
Really smelly box.
Is this all there is to load?
To the heliport, huh?
Yep.
To the heliport.
Thank you!
Yay!
I love it, Twin Snakes.
It's so, you can see him so clearly in the back in the box.
Oh, stinky.
Oh, this box smells so bad.
What is the boss putting in here?
Cool.
Alrighty, this guy's not asleep anymore.
Oh, oh, oh my god.
Just a box.
Yeah, go that way.
Is there anything under here?
No.
Yon, I'm sleepy.
Does this guy come back around too?
I know I can't use it in narrow spaces.
Please don't notice me.
Isn't there...
I think there's also rations in here.
I didn't grab them earlier.
I don't think so.
Shadow Moses is Ipy a soldier.
So Ipy.
Ipy guy.
Okay.
I feel asleep.
Yay!
We're gonna gather some supplies, everybody.
Okay, second floor basement.
I hate that area, though.
I hate it because there's the trap doors and also the guys,
they always get me in there.
Every time.
How many rations do I have now?
Two, I think?
Three!
Oh, hi, Doc!
Let's go!
Bump-bump-bump.
Meryl's incredible for surviving this long after she's being
shot three times.
I'm convinced that as soon as you leave,
she, uh...
Sniper wolf grabs her and, like, starts treating her, right?
Because when you come back, she's gone, so...
I can't leave through this one.
Nope.
Gotta be this one.
Spoilers?
Oh!
No!
I'm just saying, I think that's what happens.
That's my...
That's...
You know, don't...
Don't trust me.
Thanks for the hot dogs.
Thank you.
Is he upstairs or...
I can't tell.
The guy I'm hearing, isn't he?
Is he upstairs or is he over here?
I can't tell.
I guess he's upstairs.
Until so much MG is brainwashed, she doesn't realize when
she's spoiling anymore.
No!
Don't say that!
Even me being like, don't spoil stuff, guys.
Box time.
Stinky.
He was looking over here.
Maybe not anymore.
beep
uh was it b1 or b2 good luck man thank you
oh wait actually this will be a good place to grab some more
supply wait can I go in here oh no I only have 5 this is 6
isn't it ah
but is there like supplies in here anymore hello Nice!
Okay, now I think there's another ration in here, but I'm
gonna use this one.
Which button?
B button.
Okay, there we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Who's your favorite codec channel to talk to?
I don't know!
There's nothing under there, yeah.
Probably Master Miller.
Miller oh the basic law of CQB is to take your enemy out as
quickly and efficiently as possible I hate master Miller
maintaining your own escape route it's CQC master Miller you
poser
Otacon where is there a sniper rifle well there's a PSG one
in the oh yeah second I knew that already Campbell are you
okay are you freaking out a little bit didn't you just hear
that there's a sniper second floor basement of the tank
hangar maybe go get it and save Meryl okay sorry
sorry he's like um can you just do your job for two seconds
yeah it's right there nice okay with this we're basically
topped off which is great
percent but it's pretty dang close and we have four rations
so let me grab anything that's in here as well oh what they
blocked it rude never mind
second floor
they were having rat issues oh yeah probably
every time it gets me i think it's to the left over there
right
I think it's this room right there.
I might be wrong, though.
I might be wrong.
I'm seeing how they walk around again.
I don't remember.
It says on the door.
Yeah, but we looked earlier.
I just can't remember.
This guy down here just walks back.
I think it has to be this one because he is constantly
walking.
Look at this.
He's camping it.
It has to be this one.
This guy down here is completely camping.
Oh,
there's three guys.
he's like...
Wait, turn around and walk away, please.
Okay, I'm gonna have to...
I think I'm gonna have to choke him out.
Wait, is this guy...
This guy's gonna come down, right?
Yeah, he goes down that way.
Okay, okay, okay.
It has to be this one!
Okay, I'm waiting for him to leave a little bit more.
Okay, I think I'll be able to get him once he turns around
now.
Oh, shit!
I had my weapon equipped!
Just a box.
Oh, no, but they're back.
Okay, um...
Wait, hold on.
Where's my cigarettes at?
Oh, it's awkward.
Oh, it's weird.
Okay.
Let's, let's, um, unequip this.
If I mess up...
Uh, well, just kill me.
Just kill me.
It's okay.
We can start from this floor again.
Like that!
Okay, once this guy goes down, though, I can leave.
If I mess up, immediately messes up.
Look, okay.
Look, look.
I don't have any excuses.
Oh, the thing didn't even go off.
Unequipped.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
My right trigger is not working, you guys.
My right trigger is not working.
Hold on.
Um...
Oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh,
uh-oh, uh-oh, my left trigger is not working!
I have to unequip the box first, are you sure?
Okay, hold on.
I just want- I know he can't see me, but I don't trust it
anyway.
Oh, you're right.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
now oh my gosh that scared me that scared me so bad
whoo go go go go go um
i'm also gonna shoot at you
don't call me you got a psg yes i did you can use that
against sniper wolf i'm gonna go i'm gonna i'm hurrying oh
i'm hurrying yes i am Run, snake run!
Oh, I can't get out of here.
Ah!
Just run.
Oh my gosh.
Uh, now I have to wait for the elevator!
Please, oh my gosh.
I can't use it.
I can't use it until I'm good.
Goodbye rations.
Russians.
Why is everything against me?
Huh?
Just a box!
You don't see anything.
Don't turn this way.
Oh my goodness.
Oh god.
Anyway, we're out.
If that guy hadn't yelled for no reason, all he was doing
was choking him, why did he yell about it?
Stupid guy!
Why did he have to yell?
Why did he have to yell about getting killed?
What an idiot.
This should have been a really quiet, peaceful death.
There's still a guy in there.
Huh.
Hold on, I'm waiting for this.
I think he can't see.
Maybe.
I'm gonna unequip my weapon too.
Like a glove.
Okay, let's go back to the heliport.
How many rations do I even have left?
Me too.
I'm feeling like I should do it over.
If only I hadn't messed up the alarm before, it would have
been fine.
It's all my fault.
If only I hadn't messed up the alarm, but it's so hard!
It's so hard getting in there!
That's such a tight squeeze!
There'll be more rations in the future.
Yeah, I don't know.
But I like having full rush.
Wait.
Oh, there.
I was like, wait a second.
Here, here.
Oh.
Just gonna chill out right here.
Wait for these guys to walk away.
Oh, and then we'll get into the car.
What the heck was he doing?
I'm not gonna turn around, are you?
That's what I thought.
And to the nuclear warhead building.
Ah.
Is this all there is to load?
Maybe we can go loot the...
The, um...
The area with the gas.
Maybe there's stuff in there too.
We can go loot the area with the gas.
I think.
There's bullets and stuff over there.
I need it.
Chaff grenade.
I think that guy went up.
He doesn't turn around here, right?
Yeah.
Beep.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Wait, was it one or two?
I think it was two.
It was two.
Whoopsie.
Hold on, we're gonna go loot a little bit, my guys.
My bad.
Okay.
Here we go.
Because there's no one in here.
There's only... Look, look, and there's...
Look!
There's stuff!
I need it.
I can chaff in here.
probably.
And gas mask and chuff grenade.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh, uh, chuff, fight.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, blah, blah.
There we go.
Baby, more chuff.
Nice.
Chuff.
Wait.
If I take off the gas mask, my O2 just goes down faster.
But I need to...
Actually, can I...
Is there stuff...
I can't even tell if there's stuff in here.
You know what?
Let's just leave.
This is good enough.
It's good enough.
I don't want to waste too many chaff grenades either.
Okay.
Now let's go.
only some of the text is in japanese yeah because integral
was never released for us but you can change it to the text
of the cut scenes to be in english and stuff and the codex
but um uh yeah the text for like the actual items are in
japanese you got a psg one you can use that against sniper
wolf save Meryl.
I will!
I'm gonna go.
Master, what do you think?
Don't use your gun unless you need to.
If you can get out of a jam using just your hands and feet,
then do it.
If you can't, then go for the gun.
Thanks, Master.
You're so wise.
This guy's trying to kill me.
What is it?
Wolf, I...
Just forget it.
Don't give me the silent treatment, mister.
Campbell is like she's related.
She's her, it's, it's his niece that is related.
By a little bit of blood.
Tiny blood.
Relation.
The Chinese say it is the strong swimmer who most often
drowns.
It is because the strong swimmer overestimates his abilities
and underestimates the strength of the river.
I'm probably quite used to the mission now, but don't get
careless.
No, I'm cautious.
Maybe a little overly so.
Was there anything with the guy peeing?
Does you give me...
Will you give me a ration?
Oh, give me some bullets.
Nothing in here.
Dang.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I was just peeing.
Way too loudly.
I do feel bad, like, taking him out when he is on the
bathroom.
Like, or on the toilet, I guess.
Nothing.
Oh, it does respawn!
This place is amazing!
Yay!
Yippee!
Does this stuff respawn here too?
Oh, Meryl.
You were right over.
Oh!
Ah!
You guys were all good!
That's where she was.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
No dogs here.
None, actually.
We're good.
It was Box A.
Five, six, seven, oh nine.
Oh, uh, thank you.
Love you, too.
Oh, you're just one of my fans, huh?
Yeah, one of my fans, one of my fans.
Is it here?
Oh, gosh, wait.
Hold on.
No, no, it's...
It's there.
Okay, I'm gonna need you guys to, like, skip back a little.
Here, let's lead him over here.
Come here, come here.
Oh, I'll take that, actually.
That's pretty good to have.
Come over here.
Okay, there we go, there we go.
Oh.
Oh, you're following mid-robot and off-guy.
Stop!
Okay, good dog.
Sit.
Good boy.
And sit.
Stay.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Where is it?
Here.
Okay.
We're good.
Nice!
I always, I was gonna say, I always thought there was a rash
in here, and there is!
Okay, very good.
Alright, time for a battle.
Oh, wrong button.
May, well, I guess it doesn't really matter, but...
You caught Snake?
Yeah, I'm just gonna say, if I'm being caught, you know,
Psycho Mantis kind of got to me too.
She said I was risky.
I don't feel that way.
There's a Chinese proverb, the mind cannot be in two places
at once.
Make sure that you're not thinking of something else during
the mission, okay?
Okay.
Stay out of her range and shoot at her with a sniper rifle.
I'm not so good at this one, I think.
Because it's hard to...
I feel like it's hard when she is...
Okay, we got the Daisa as a pan.
Um.
Alright, hold on.
PSG 1.
Boom, boom, boom.
It's always hard for me to get an angle here.
I mean.
That's my...
That's the toughest part for me is how to get the angle
here.
Without getting...
Look, without getting shot by her!
Uh...
Like, what is...
What is the good strategy here?
like angel or angle angle like what's the what's the what's
the just rod dog it no go further back but she can see me
right she'll be able to see me back there oh what's the best
way just run out and aim quick oh gosh you have a spray and
pray that's not really an option here is it?
Press against the wall and you can see when she's aiming.
You can.
Oh, look at this!
She knows exactly where I am!
Oh.
She gave up.
I thought she never gives up.
I thought she'll be here for months, for weeks, for ever.
I thought she just lives and breathes this part, you know.
She knows exactly where I am, though.
Maybe.
Hold on.
When she turns around, or when she gives up, I'm going to
run to the other side.
Oh, she totally saw where I went.
She totally saw where I went.
Didn't even matter.
Oh my god, is that?
Are those the little rats upstairs?
Do you see them moving around?
They're so cute.
They're just little, actually one pixels of rats.
That's so funny.
Okay.
So where was she at?
Where'd she go?
Okay, she's behind the pillar.
Oh.
Whoa.
It's so slow.
Why is it so slow?
Oh, it's because of me.
Don't hit me.
Don't hit.
This one is so annoying to me again because it's like, how
the heck, how the heck do I get to her?
Okay, maybe I take a dice as a Pam here.
I mean, I need to shoot.
Where are you?
Oh.
There we go.
You know, this time's the charm.
Can I get her hand?
Ow!
Dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun Oh, uh...
Ugh.
And ration!
And sh- Oh!
Wait, does Azepam not work?
I took- Oh, I didn't take it.
Take it!
There we go.
Okay, where is she?
Uh...
I'm lost?
I'm lost for real.
Okay.
Don't- Ouch!
Stop shooting me!
I'm trying to get into position!
Oh, there she is.
Yeah!
Get
out!
Don't do it!
Ah!
Even if I can just get her...
She missed.
Oh my god!
How did that miss?
I'm sorry!
What?
Come on.
That was one pixel off.
That's crazy.
I'm just gonna run back.
I just got back here.
If this is the battle I have to do again, I'm gonna scream.
Where is she even?
Ah!
Oh, that was me.
That was all me.
I can't believe I did that.
Oh my gosh, Sniper Wolf, please!
You!
These controls are trying to, like, get as little of the
movement as...
There we go.
Oh,
they're so awkward.
The controls, I know.
I got her too, though.
I only have three bullets left!
Wait.
Uh-oh.
I only have three bullets left.
Hmm.
That's no good, is it?
Make them count.
Yeah, for sure.
Three bullets.
Okay.
And not a lot of Daiso Japan left either.
Oh my god.
I'm so slow!
I'm so slow.
Slow it turning!
I just turned!
Please, sniper wolf, please!
Wait, where is she?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
It's okay.
Snake, answer me!
Snake!
It's okay.
The controls here are so awkward.
Alrighty.
We got this.
No need to worry about bullets.
Yeah, right?
So true.
Okay.
Alright.
And, uh...
Looks like you're redoing this one.
Yeah, that's okay, though.
Not gonna get all of them.
Oh my gosh.
Please, though.
If I could just get in a decent angle when I, like,
initially start, it'll save me so much, you know?
There we go, there we go, that's better, that's better.
Okay, where is she?
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
Don't shoot me.
Cut
her?
Okay.
I don't know how I managed that one, to be honest.
Sometimes her hitboxes.
Ouch!
Oh, I need to put on my rations again.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, no.
Going to this side.
How many bullets do I have?
I clicked it.
Come on.
Show your face.
That side.
What the hell?
Oh, yeah.
Got her?
Beam it up just a little bit.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Come on.
Can I get me from here?
What a shooting pose.
Okay.
That was a good position.
Oh my god.
I'm bay blading again.
Sniper wolf won't be able to hit me if I fly at her like
this.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right.
It should be good.
Okay.
And that is a spam.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Oh,
please, please.
No!
I forgot to equip my ration again!
Oh, it's the switching between it.
Ah, I had her.
I had her.
That's the switching.
Dang it.
I forgot to.
Oh, I forgot to.
Dang it!
This is- it's funny that this is the one causing me the most
grief right now.
I say grief very lightly, like I'm- I don't- it's only-
whatever.
Oh, can you get up, Snake?
It's only the third try.
It's just a little bit annoying.
Oh!
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
Does it pop-up-pump?
Russian?
Ah!
Headshot!
Oh, headshot!
Oh, dang it.
Oh, she got me too.
Run, run,
run.
Don't shoot, don't shoot, don't shoot.
Okay.
Don't shoot.
No, stop.
Let me get into position, please.
Okay.
Oh, don't hit, don't hit.
Oh, oh my god.
Where is she?
I think she's behind me.
There she is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got you too.
Oh, I got you too.
No.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Can I get her from here?
Yeah.
Oh, ouch.
How'd you get me even?
It's just...
Getting into position is so hard for me.
Oh, she tried, she tried.
Oh my god, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't
shoot, don't shoot, don't shoot!
Okay, okay, good, good, good, good.
Okay, good, good, good.
That is a PAM.
Come on, Wolf.
Come on.
Nice.
Yippee!
Are the cameras here yet?
I can't remember.
Take that.
There's one, what?
One down here?
right maybe not
time to take a little bit of stuff a little bit yippee take
some what with some bullets please thank you I'll take that
what else is around here over there over there I'm a gamer
I'm a soldier call me Ling oh me Ling I did it Snake,
wouldn't now be a good time to save your mission?
What's going on?
Oh, she's got a bad feeling.
I'm getting a bad feeling.
Oh.
Bad feeling.
Like a premonition or something.
A premonition.
She's so smart.
Snake, it's all up to you.
I love when she says that, and there's no BGM.
You just have, like, the, oh, you know, you just have the
wind and stuff.
It's so creepy.
It's so unnerving.
Good job with Wolf.
Meryl okay I don't know I don't see her around you don't
think she's been captured do you could be let's ask wolf if
she's still alive I'm gonna get some answers oh snake about
Meryl I'm counting on you yeah master what do you have to
say about me being a gamer snake divide and conquer try to
take your enemies on one at a time okay I haven't talked to
Nostasha in a while let's see what she says it is so ironic
people are working as slaves to pay for weapons that must
never be used once again off topic love that for her love
you nastasha
he doesn't even talk to me at all come on come on oticon oh
i like the blood drops here that's like a good Attention to
detail.
That's so cool.
And also the ones going down the stairs, so you can tell.
I mean, she's not there.
She must have escaped.
Right?
Hmm.
Okay.
Nostasia.
Ah!
I don't even have a level 6 key.
I wouldn't have even be able to get past.
It's hard to miss when you're this close.
Toss your way.
weapon over here.
Now, don't take my weapon.
You are a fool to come back here, stupid man.
A lady sniper, huh?
Lady sniper.
Didn't you know that two-thirds of the world's greatest
assassins are women?
You tell him.
Do you want to die now?
Or after your female friend?
Which will it be?
I'll die after I kill you.
Is that right?
Well, at least you got spirit.
I am sniper wolf.
And I always kill what I aim at.
She is so awesome.
You're my special prey.
I like how my controller vibrated when she grabbed my face.
Oh, I've left my mark on you.
I won't forget it.
Until I kill you, you're all I think about.
Oh my god.
I got knocked out by a lady.
Yippee!
Can you be as awesome as sniper wolf mint?
No, I don't think so.
Don't kill me yet.
I'm a mom.
Leave it to me.
Oh, yeah, we're gonna leave it to you.
Oh, I saw that.
Yes, he's my target.
My...
Her accent's so beautiful.
Oh.
Hello.
Can you hear him, solid snake?
He's tougher than I thought.
Do you know who I am?
No!
I always knew that one day I would meet you.
Where are you?
The man who...
stole what was rightly mine the man who stole my birth you
mash too fast during the torture it'll trigger the auto
firefly i don't think i've ever mashed that hard enough
forget it your body is strapped down tight let me out you
kinky man i'm the man you stole everything good from oh my
eyes now after the sacrifice of our brothers after 30 long
years finally the two of us meet the brother of light and
the brother of dark brothers let me out you need his DNA too
yes oh I want to sample while he's still alive we needed to
correct the genome soldiers mutations then we'll be able to
cure them no we still have to get our hands on big bosses
DNA they suffer from stupid hey show yourself come on have
they given in to our demands yet not yet not they won't give
in they're all hypocrites every one of them is that your
opinion has occurred they always put politics first that's
right that's why they want to avoid any leak about their
precious new nuclear weapon boss it looks like our friend is
awake i've been awake oh thank you oh hi liquid there
definitely is a resemblance don't you think little brother
or should i say big brother i'm not sure anyway it doesn't
matter who came out first you and i are both the last
surviving sons of big boss oh it's me really then what do
those idiots all right Raven I'll be right there they're not
responding to our demands oh we launched the first one in
ten hours as planned damn Americans oh my god looks like you
read them wrong something's funny normally the Americans are
the first ones to negotiating table they must think they've
got something up their sleeves so it's come down to it about
to say they think they have an ace up their sleeves and ride
it all the way into history I've got to take care of some
launch preparations you're in charge here Ocelot what about
you want to stay for the show I'm not interested it's time
to feed the family she's got to take her does as a pen so
you prefer your wolves to my show Yeah.
Ocelot, don't screw up like you did with the chief.
Yes, I know.
That was an accident.
I didn't think a pencil pusher like him would be so tough.
Well, his mental defenses were reinforced by hypnotherapy.
Boss, what about that mint?
He's killed 12 men.
Whoever he is, he's some kind of lunatic.
Bastard took my hand.
How could he have gotten in here?
Perhaps there's a spy among us.
Among us?
Mantis is dead.
I've got to find out what killed Baker, an octopus.
We're short-handed.
So make this little torture show of yours as short as
possible.
I can't wait to fight him.
This is an interrogation.
As you wish.
See you later, brother.
Short-handed.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
You're a woman is still in this world.
Merrill.
Catch you later, handsome.
Once she picks a target, she doesn't think about anything
else.
Sometimes she even falls in love with him.
These camera angles.
Just the two of us.
How are you feeling?
We can make it.
Cut a nice nap on this revolving bed.
Too bad I was sleeping alone.
Oh!
I'm glad to hear that.
This is some bed all right.
I'm about to show you some of its nicer features.
It's a sneaky little flirt.
Anyone that moves.
They're all there.
Washington was taking quite a chance sending you here.
Someone must have had a lot of faith in your skill, huh?
Carrier boy.
So, Metal Gear is armed with a new type of nuclear warhead,
huh?
Why don't you go ask Campbell for the full story?
Colonel.
The Colonel?
By the way, you got an optical disc from President Baker,
didn't you?
What if I did?
Is that the only disc?
there's no other data what do you mean what do you mean
there's no copy you're not that's fine is Merrill okay I
don't even know how to turn on turbo wolf must have been
feeling generous Wow you wanted to stay that way you better
start answering my questions right now okay you were holding
one card key yeah where the other two what's the trick
behind that key I don't know trick that weasel of a Or
treat.
Or treat.
Hell if I know.
I see.
No problem then.
I'm going to play a game, Snake.
A game?
And we'll find out what kind of man you really are.
When the pain becomes too great to bear, just give up and
your suffering will end.
Just give up.
What if you do?
The girl's life is mine.
No!
Are you gonna fight or submit?
I'm gonna fight.
Press the circle button repeatedly to regain your strength.
enough press the select button to submit I said in the when
your life reaches zero the game is over there are no
continues my friend don't even think about using auto fire
or I'll know hell no I'm going to run a high voltage
electric current through your body if it's just for a short
time it won't kill you I don't even think about using auto
fire you're a tough guy how do you news for you you're no
POW you're a hostage there's no Geneva Convention no one is
coming to save you starting to feel a little scared no good
you should be he doesn't even say anything lots a lot I said
this in the first stream of this okay here we go but because
I'm playing through like the series I I decided that I want
to play
The um The true ending rather You know So that's why I'm
gonna play it
Ha Oh
Oh my god Hold on I'm gonna put it on the desk We're not
finished yet Okay okay okay okay Now it's not in my lap Okay
Oh my finger hurt!
You're a strong man.
Well that's enough for now, huh?
Thank you guys for the breeze.
You're the boss's brother, all right.
Your brother, he's an amazing man.
Who else could shoot down two F-16s with a hind helicopter?
The Les Enfantarii Project was not a total failure.
He is the one man who could make my dream into a reality.
Like so...
Who's dragging me away?
My stuff!
Give me my stuff!
Les infantiles.
Oh.
Oh, gross!
The DARPA chief?
Why'd they keep him in here?
What a stench.
Nasty.
Looks like he's been dead for days.
That witch.
Shut up
in there, will ya?
I love that he's naked in the codec.
Snake, the government has decided not to give in to their
demands.
Yeah, I heard.
We're trying to buy some more time.
Come on, Colonel.
Come on.
Why don't you stop playing dumb?
I'm sorry about Merrill, but I want the lies to end now.
What are you talking about?
Metal Gear was designed to launch a new type of nuclear
warhead.
wasn't it it was you knew it all along didn't you oh colonel
i'm so disappointed i'm sorry colonel can't tell the grunts
huh you've changed a lot metal gear secret advanced nuclear
weapons research does the white house know about this how
deep does it go as far as i know as of yesterday the
president had not been briefed about the rex project uh-huh
need to know basis is that the idea These are sensitive
times.
Even sub-critical nuclear tests are causing quite a stir.
Plausible deniability, huh?
Yes.
And tomorrow, the President and his Russian counterpart are
scheduled to sign the Start Three Accord.
I get it.
That's the reason for the deadline.
That's right, Snake.
And that's why we can't let this terrorist attack go public.
We still haven't even ratified Start Two, or dealt with the
issue of TMDs.
This has to do with the President's reputation.
and America's place is the dominant superpower.
So patriotism is your excuse for circumventing the
Constitution?
Please, Snake.
Yippee, more MDS.
Thank you!
Why should I?
Because you're the only one who can.
In that case, tell me the truth about this new type of
nuclear warhead.
I told you before.
I don't know the details.
I don't believe you.
If the situation is so serious, why don't you give in to
their demands?
big bosses remains you see or is there some reason that you
can't do that something you haven't told me about publicly
the president has been very vocal in his opposition to
eugenics experiments right don't want the existence of the
genome army to go public and that's the only reason oh come
on you coward with you I'm sorry you coward the corpse of
the DARPA chief is lying right here next to me oh man but
it's strange he looks and smells like he's been dead for
days all this blood's been drained out too drained drained
to slow down decomposition I have no idea but the chief only
died a few hours ago right yeah but he's already started to
decompose what could it all be about something in his blood
that they wanted I doubt it just the nanomachines in the
transmitter did the chief tell them his detonation code I'm
afraid so apparently yeah it looks like they've got both
codes and are nearly ready to launch is there any way to
prevent it it seems that there's some type of emergency
override device that can cancel out the detonation code it's
a countermeasure that arms tech installed secretly you have
to unlock it with three special card keys and where are
those keys I've got one maybe there's a bisexual a foot
besides I'm locked forget about the keys your top priority
now is to destroy metal gear itself okay sorry to have to
lay it all in your lap but you're all I've got well maybe
you should be more honest with me also also you're asking
for a whole lot you're asking for a whole lot Colonel I'll
save her thanks Wow Wow how's master doing When a soldier is
taken prisoner, he should only give up the Big Four.
The Big Four.
That's name, rank, serial number, and date of birth.
Uh-huh.
But you're not any old soldier, Snake.
Why those things?
I don't want you to tell them anything.
Oh, okay.
Fortunately, you're strong enough to resist.
Yeah!
Uh, Nostasha?
Just because you are locked up does not mean there is no
chance of escape.
Keep your eyes in here, though.
And when you see a chance, take it.
Take it.
Otacon, come get me out of here.
Otacon, are you still okay?
Yeah.
Thanks to the stealth camouflage, that is.
I have a favor to ask.
I need your help.
I was wondering when you'd ask.
Yeah.
What should I do?
I've been captured.
I'm locked up here in this cell.
What cell?
There's a big torture machine nearby.
Yeah.
Okay.
I know it.
It's close.
Why do you know this?
Why do you know the torture machine, Otakon?
Why did you... Okay, first of all, you were like, I think
I'm making things for good.
I'm making machines to be like my Japanese animas, but then
you see the giant torture device and you're just like, these
are the good guys.
What?
Why'd you...
What's up with that?
Bless you.
Shut up in there, will ya?
No king shaming.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm not king shaming, I'm not king shaming.
I have to do it another time, right?
To get, um, I want to try the ketchup.
Shut up in there, will ya?
you shut up look at his his he's got such range of his
vision sniper wolf in him use the the torture device oh it's
showtime it's showtime okay all right my finger has been uh
given enough time maybe to recover
okay okay i'll tell you once more yes press the circle
button repeatedly to regain your strength okay when you've
had enough press the select button to submit when your life
reaches zero the game is over there are no continues my
friend and he means it i fought wars in afghanistan he means
that mozambique eritrea and chad among the mujahideen
guerrillas i was known and feared as shalashaska i was
trained by the worship group i am not like one of those kgb
slugs oh to me this isn't torture oh it's a sport You're all
just a bunch of sadists.
You're such a freak.
Oh my god, you're such a freak.
Shall we begin?
Okay, here we go.
Okay, here we go, here we go, guys.
You
know why I think it's more difficult for me this time?
The buttons are bigger.
Shall we go again?
When I did it on the PS1 controller last time, it was so
much easier.
Because the buttons were more shallow!
Had enough yet?
We're not finished yet.
Say no.
You're a strong man.
Well, that's enough for now.
Thank you.
Thank you, Oslo.
We live in a sad age.
In a society.
Imperialism, totalitarianism, Perestroika.
20th century Russia has had its share of problems, but at
least they had an ideology.
Russia today has nothing.
They're struggling between freedom and order, and with that
struggle, a new spirit of nationalism has been born.
The boss has a close friend high up in the Russian
government.
Who could that be?
He's agreed to purchase this new nuclear weapons system.
The HIND was just a down payment.
So you're in this for money?
I don't need money.
I want Russia to be reborn.
Yeah.
To lead a brave new world order.
That's why he's doing it.
Yeah.
We got you.
We got you, Oslo.
Bye.
so do i have to do it one more time or am i good now
i guess we wait for him to go to the bathroom right oticon
where are you oticon i'm headed your way now can't you just
relax this is life or death i am relaxed i just don't know
how to kill time here okay i'll be there as soon as i can
relaxed i am relaxed you okay snake yeah nothing new to
report snake equals dead anything i can do yeah my arm hurts
poor snake i'll increase the level of painkillers in your
blood okay but you can leave out the benzodrine that stuff
makes me too frisky i guess you're not feeling too bad after
all snake put the controller up against your arm okay what
don't worry it's up against my arm huh okay here i go that
felt good how does it feel snake a little better how did you
do that I stimulated your muscle fibers with the nanomachine
cilia Wow that's about all I can do for you Naomi please
talk to me say something to take my mind off the pain this
guy I say this guy I'm not a very good talker please please
tell me about I hurt our Naomi.
That's a tough one.
Any family?
That's not a happy topic for me.
I don't have any family.
No, wait.
There was a man who said he was my father.
Where is he?
Dead by my own hand.
Big boss.
Big boss?
I had no idea.
There was no way you could.
It happened in Zanzibar six years ago only six years ago the
snake and i know the real truth of what happened there he
was so green back then is it true was big boss really your
father that's what he said that's all i know and you were
able to kill him knowing that yep
besides some people just need killing that's petricide yep
that's the drama that mantis was talking about The one we
share in common.
Is that why you left Foxhound?
Let's just say that I needed to be alone for a while.
And Alaska was the perfect place.
I didn't have a real family either.
Just a big brother who put me through school.
We weren't even blood-related, and he was much older than
me.
Where is he?
He's dead.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, I'm messaging Mitara at the same time.
We're trying to figure out when to record.
After you've been through as many wars as me, it's hard to
trust anyone.
Friends.
Roy Campbell.
You're still calling me friend?
Barely.
No.
There was another.
Frank Yeager.
What?
Big boss's most trusted lieutenant.
And the only member of Foxhound ever to receive the code
name Fox.
Gray Fox.
I learned a lot from him.
But...
You try to kill each other.
That's true.
Gray Fox!
We did it in Sanzibar.
But it was nothing personal.
We were just professionals on opposite sides.
That's all.
And you still call yourself friends?
Hard to believe.
War is no reason to end a friendship.
That's crazy.
That's insane.
The first man in the movie.
Oh no, it's the first time I've agreed with Naomi.
He was being held a prisoner of outer heaven.
But he didn't look like a prisoner to me.
He was always so cool and precise.
I was still green.
And he showed me the ropes.
You knew him well?
No.
We never talked about our personal lives.
Sort of an unwritten rule.
We just were buddies.
We were war buddies.
We were enemies.
We were fighting barehanded in a minefield.
Yeah, I did that one.
I know it sounds strange to most people.
But we were just two soldiers doing our jobs.
It's like a sport.
You sound like Ocelot.
You're like wild animals.
You're right.
We are animals.
Just do what's being do.
So if you were friends, then how do you explain the ninja's
behavior?
I don't know.
It's your genes.
They make you predisposed towards violence.
You really like talking about genes, Naomi.
Why did you get into genetic research anyway?
I never knew who my parents were.
I don't know.
I guess I got into genetics because I wanted to figure out
why i am the way i am so you said about dna yeah i thought
if i studied my genetic structure i'd find out who i really
was i thought that by analyzing a person's genetic
information i could retrieve the blank spots in that
person's memory memory is stored in dna we're not sure but
we know that a person's genetic fate is determined just by
the sequence of the four bases in their dna so what about my
fate you know my dna sequence don't you your fate i've i'm
sorry i have no idea of course not of course you're a
scientist not a fortune teller why'd you say it like that
though why'd you say it like that though can bromance bloom
on the battlefield master don't say anything to tease or
anger the person torturing you if you make him mad it'll be
that much worse Oh, I'm gonna tease him.
Ooh, la-la.
Otakon, where the hell are you?
I'm headed your way now.
Can't you just relax?
Ugh.
Where are you?
Hey.
Shut up in there, will you?
Shut up.
Oh.
Oh, my stomach.
Oh, no.
Oh, damn it.
Oh, there he goes.
There he goes.
Oh,
God.
I'm glad this place is pretty soundproof, so...
Oh?
Oh.
I'm here.
Oh, I can't see you.
It's me.
Otakon.
They even capture you.
Hurry, get me out of here.
Get me out of here!
Let me go.
That hurts.
Hurry up.
Yes.
Is that how you ask a guy a favor?
Oh my god, they're so close.
Jeez.
It's like an animal's cage.
Why is everybody comparing me to an animal today?
Because of him.
Yeah, stinkier.
Stinkier.
over there it's the derpa chief the derpa chief i'll be
laying next to him the derpa chief bastard this lock won't
open with a security you killed kenneth those bastards so
what are you doing here then i i thought you might be hungry
if you need more food i can bring some more later tiny
ration also i got you this level six it'll get you out of
that torture room yes here take this too what's this it's a
handkerchief i got it from sniper wolf why i don't know why
but she's nice to why are you giving it to him sounds like
stockholm syndrome to me what does i was taking care of the
dogs here after the terrorists i guess if you're eating
rations putting ketchup on it could help right but sniper
wolf stopped him she even let me feed him when i asked oh
she likes dogs she must be a good person so true please
don't hurt her wake up you idiot she's the one who shot
maryl she likes dogs well that's all i can do she likes
animals i've got to stop them then you have to get past the
communications tower first you have to get me out of here
come on i'm trying my best that guard's got the key you'll
have to take him out give me a break i'm no soldier okay you
can't take anybody out you have to that's a lot
He's coming back!
Oh geez.
See you later.
Bye!
Okay, catch up.
I don't... Oh, B button.
Okay.
Here I go.
Ew!
We're just gonna not worry about this next part, okay?
What the?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, come here.
We're just gonna not worry about that.
What just happened?
Okay, everything's good.
We're just gonna...
Not worry about that, okay?
Um...
Everybody, it's fine.
Everybody, we're, it's all good.
Where does my stuff at?
Whoa.
Oh, let's go get changed.
Should I just kill Johnny?
No, no, no.
Hold on the bomb for a call.
Yes, I actually was going to mention that.
I actually was going to say, I know that there is a bomb in
my inventory, but I'm going to hold on to it.
some funny cutscene or funny codex stuff that I want to see.
Or not funny, but some codex stuff I want to see.
To get to the underground base where Metal Gear is, you'll
have to climb the communications tower on the north side of
the cave.
Now that you've got your stuff back, you should take a good
look through it.
If you're slow equipping an item in battle, it could mean
death.
Shush.
The future will be changed.
You've created a time paradox.
No!
I said, everything's fine, you guys.
Everything's all good.
Everything's fine.
So you figured out what I had in mind, huh?
I can't believe it actually worked.
He's such a genius.
Oh, it was Otakon's idea the whole time.
Johnny has a really strong neck.
Okay.
What else is around here?
I think we just got to go through there.
I got to use...
Is there anything in the bathroom besides like...
I hope it's clean.
Please be clean.
Okay.
Let's use a chaff.
I only have nine though.
Oh, oops.
Hey.
Only stinky.
Definitely stinky.
Oh!
That was close.
Ah!
Okay.
Um, I think we got everything in here.
Actually, let's do that.
Let's take out...
Let's grab this.
Okay, let's leave.
Alrighty.
Okie dokie.
Now we have to go all the way back.
So much fun.
It's my favorite part.
Love, love, love.
Love backtracking, everybody.
Backtracking my beloved.
Wait.
Is there a good way to get through these?
It's like impossible, isn't it?
Do I have to chaff here?
Johnny is dead.
Time paradox.
It's totally possible.
Oh.
Oh, it doesn't see me as far as I thought it would.
Okay, I did it.
Easy peasy.
Oh.
I'm just gonna go, I think, through here.
Is it turned off now?
Do I...
At some point it gets turned off, doesn't it?
Oh!
I think it's turned off!
Yippee!
I have to go to the bathroom real quick, I think.
That's okay.
It's not so bad.
Are the mines back, I wonder?
I don't remember.
Yes.
This is why we always check.
This is why we're overly cautious.
It feels like there's even more than before.
they put in a ton of them.
Oh my god.
There's a ton and ton of them.
It's an absolute minefield.
Craziness.
Well, I can just run through it.
Oh.
Snake, there's a bomb planet in your items.
What?
Throw it away.
Who the hell are you?
One of them?
You'll find out soon enough.
Okay.
Oh my god, there's... What do you mean?
There's a bomb planted in my items!
Ah!
Colonel!
To get to the underground base for Metal Gear is, you'll
have to climb the communications tower on the north side of
the gate.
A bomb, a bomb, a bomb, a bomb, a bomb!
Oh my god, I only have 60 seconds left on it.
Oh yeah, Call Master, I didn't know before.
Let me see, if I call him after, I know there was something.
sound travels better in cold environments if you're going to
use a handgun you should equip a suppressor thank you okay
let's get rid of this bomb wait oh wait wait how do I get
rid of it wait oh there we go we that
was a close one snake that was a close one ocelot you'll pay
for that that deep throat's a real enigma he's definitely an
informer maybe some kind of renegade I've got the feeling
there's some other force at work here oh wait hold on master
that was too close snake it was yeah that was quite a
surprise all right hiding a bomb in your items that's a
despicable act he should never oh well and forget it you'd
better hurry to the underground base you're almost out of
time Oh!
He should never.
Bless you, thank you.
What do you mean by that, Master?
He should never would.
If you go straight down the underground passageway north of
the cave, you'll arrive at the communication towers.
Yeah.
You should be able to go over the glacier by using the
communication towers walkway.
Head for the towers.
Okay.
Anyway, mine detector.
Oh my god, I forgot.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh, there's so many mines and then there's also the
cameras.
Let's grab this.
This.
Oh, oh shoot.
Uh oh, I can't keep any more of them.
Okay, so now I have to avoid the camera and also avoid the
bombs.
This is very fun.
I like this.
Maybe I should have just taken the shortcut.
Maybe.
Let's go this way.
What the?
Oh, it scared me so bad.
Oh,
my gosh.
Oh, it has spooked me.
Like crazy.
What?
How did you see me?
Oh, am I okay?
Oh wait, no, I need this, I need the...
Wait, can I see them with the night vision?
Ah, I can't see anything with the night vision!
Look how many claymores there are.
It's so crazy.
Walks in front of camera, how did you see me?
I thought I walked under it!
What are you talking about?
I'm looking at my little dot.
Okay, I'm looking at my little dot.
There we go.
Let me in, let me in, let me in, let me in.
It's not so bad.
But from here, I am going to go to the bathroom real quick.
I hope you guys don't mind.
But I'm going to go to the bathroom.
But actually, I think he'll be able to see me.
So we'll crawl like that.
I'll be right back.
And I'm going to get some more tea also.
So I'll be right back.
You guys can listen to this.
And just enjoy the music and the ambience.
BRB.
Better wash your hands.
I always do.
Okay, beer.
I almost just spilled my tea.
I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
Welcome
back, thank you.
We are no longer fishing, scatter!
No, get in here, get in here.
Get in here, get in here.
Welcome back, thank you!
What kind of tea is it?
Just some green tea.
Okie dokie Alright, this guy just left So perfect timing for
us Let's go
And I'm gonna become a
box Wait, I think that was the Was that the guy upstairs or
downstairs?
I can't tell Oh, okay, okay, okay, whoa Now I know there's
chaff grenades over there though So I'm gonna grab them Just
a box Just a box Just a box Why does the category say MGS2?
Oh, it dies?
Oh, that's so weird.
Could have sworn I put in MGS1.
Oh, I'll change it.
Thanks for letting me know.
I had no idea.
Shelf, grenades.
Oh, perfect timing.
I'm
going to wait for it to be.
I'm scared.
This is one for me.
That's so weird.
I don't know.
Oh my god, I did it again.
No, we're going to the basement.
We're going to basement one.
This is MGS part two.
As in, it is in, as in, it is day two.
Yes, that is correct.
It is the day two or the second time of me streaming.
Metal Gear Solid.
2.
1.
Part 2.
Even my brain can't understand.
Even my brain can't handle it.
Yay!
Wait.
My health is good.
Life is good.
Afterlife is good.
For me it says Old Metal Gear 1987 game.
What?
What is up with MewTube?
I swear.
MewTube doesn't know anything, I think.
Don't attack me.
I'm just a box.
I'm just a box that you love.
Oh, gosh.
I can't see anything in here.
Oh, I don't need those.
Okay.
Thank you.
I love you too.
Love
you too, love you too.
We're good.
Are the bombs here again?
Or...
I'm just gonna crawl anyway.
I can't remember.
I don't think so.
I think they're gone, gone.
Oh.
Um, my immersion?
I was crawling to that part.
Ew, there's cat hair in my tea!
What?
Sorry, Meryl.
I'm sad about you too.
More sad about my tea.
I'm sad.
How did I get in there?
Oh.
The normal cat life.
I... I... I... I can still help.
I want to help you.
Boy it down.
Save your strength.
I was a fool.
I wanted to be a soldier.
She wanted to be a soldier, you guys.
But war is ugly.
There's nothing glamorous about it.
Snake, please save me.
yourself go on living and don't give up on people don't
forget me
his PTSD snake about Merrill Colonel I'm sorry listen to me
I wasn't able to protect her no snake she's a soldier she
knows that prisoners are a part of She joined up of her own
free will I'm sure she was prepared for this.
No, you're very understanding how all of a sudden Merrill
thought she had to become a soldier Thought it was the only
way She said she thought it would bring her closer to her
dead father.
She said that She wasn't ready for real combat.
I shouldn't have pushed her so hard It's all my fault.
It's not like you snake.
Oh master What is it?
Sorry for eavesdropping, but I just couldn't listen anymore.
Master.
You can have regrets if you want to.
It's only natural.
But you can't keep attacking yourself for things that
happened in the past.
That road leads to madness.
Believe me.
He's right.
Don't kick yourself.
It doesn't suit a legend like you.
I'm sure Meryl's just fine.
Mei Ling.
Snake.
Forget about Meryl.
Stop liquid.
That's what Merrill would want to.
Yeah, Merrill's still alive.
Don't talk like she's dead.
Merrill would say the same thing.
I didn't submit, okay?
What?
Merrill, she's pretty special to you, huh?
Don't- don't undermine my abilities like that.
There aren't many women like her around.
That's not what I meant.
She's the Colonel's niece and a combat buddy.
A combat buddy?
Come on.
This is like a police interrogation.
No, I just- What do you mean by that?
What are you talking about, Colonel?
No, I just remembered about Naomi's grandfather.
I think Naomi said he rose as high as Assistant Secretary in
the FBI during Edgar Hoover's time.
Is that right?
Yes, yes, he was Japanese, and he became a special
undercover investigator to nab the mafia.
When was that?
Oh?
Sometime in the 50s, I guess.
Where?
Oh?
A New York, I think.
Oh, I thought you didn't have any family.
Oh, master clocking her?
Oh, I researched it after I became an adopt.
My grandfather was already dead by the time I learned about
him.
I never even had the chance to meet him.
Oh, snake.
Good luck.
Not Colonel, just being like, oh.
Suss, suss, suss.
Naomi, so suss.
I don't remember where the cameras are at.
I know it's that middle one down there, I'm pretty sure.
I don't think there's any in here.
Bling.
You can hear it eventually.
That is a trap.
Ah!
Diarrhea is hereditary.
It runs in your jeans.
No!
No, it doesn't, please.
Someone said to shoot the rats for a special codec.
I've never gotten that one before.
but I don't know if I want to waste any dice as a Pam.
Have you played unmetal?
I haven't yet, actually.
I would like to try it someday.
The crows, too?
I think I shot a crow in the twin snakes.
The rats, though.
Shoot the rats?
Oh, there's more up there.
I'm trying to get more.
We're going to need this.
We're gonna need it.
Oh, oh, this is just PSG.
Okie dokie.
If I shoot it, if I...
I know where the rats were.
I knew where they were.
Do I... How do I get them though?
With a sniper?
I guess I'll try it once.
Don't see me.
Oh, here.
Actually, I could probably do it from here.
Let's try it.
I'm curious.
Rat.
I can't go any higher.
I have to go far far.
Okay, hold on.
I'm not gonna use any dyes of him.
I'm just gonna do it.
I'm a gamer.
I'm a gamer!
I shot the rat!
Who do I call?
To get to the underground base where metal...
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Nastasha, I shot that rat.
So, the terrorists intentionally set their deadline to
coincide with the signing of the start three accord.
Oh, need three kills.
Okay.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Oh, this was really long.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, Nastasha.
I'm sorry, Nistasha!
I'm sorry.
There's another little rat.
Oh my goodness, the shaky cam is crazy.
Let me use the cigarettes instead so that...
It's not so bad.
I don't know if you can hear my controller.
Oh gosh.
Two!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's gonna be motion sick a little.
Oh,
dang it.
Dang it.
Come here, rats.
I'll shoot you all down.
Ah!
You're so fast.
Oh, come here, little rat.
Oh my gosh, the shaky cam, for real.
Hello?
Snake, we don't need a rat trap.
We need someone to stop that goddamn nuke from getting
launched.
Sorry, Colonel.
He seemed pretty disappointed in me, you guys.
I think he was kind of mad, for real.
I think he seemed really disappointed in me.
I'm not gonna lie.
He's angry.
In we go!
Oh.
of stuff here.
Why is the music so eerie?
This way.
I
don't remember what to do here.
Hold on.
I am?
Oh god.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh god.
No!
Leave me alone!
Leave me alone, you freak!
Leave me alone, you leave me alone!
Why are you so obsessed with me?
so oh my gosh oh god
am i gonna make it oh my god i remember this okay hold on i
do remember i remember this part now but i think i'm gonna
die i might have to redo it anyway that's okay though i
remember i think um i don't have a lot of stun grenades
though there
we go sorry guys you probably were like that in the comments
and I forgot.
Oh, no!
Throw the grenade, Snake!
Ouch!
Okay, okay, hold on.
Why are there so many of you guys?
Just keep running, Snake.
Just keep running.
The next one.
Flashbang!
That was a waste.
That's okay.
Zero, one HP in a dream, baby.
Leave me alone!
Ration?
Climb!
No!
I was right there!
I
just got to the ration too even.
Okay, okay.
I don't have a lot of flash or a lot of...
I don't... The reason I forgot about the stun grenades is
because they don't give you any.
I only have three!
They must give you more here, right?
Or they don't.
into.
I think one of those.
So I think they give you more stun grenades and then they
give you the rope.
You have to avoid the alert.
I think the alert, you have to do it though, right?
Like a bunch of guys climbed up the ladder after you at MGS
3.
I would cry.
Yeah, the alert is scripted.
Yeah, you have to go through.
this unfortunately but also i don't think it would work the
chaff because like it's already our thing is already jammed
so okay okay okay okay okay okay um i'm gonna stun as much
as i can and then and then and then fam famus start with the
famus you think so start with it and then use the stuns
Yeah, I wonder what the speedrunning trick probably just
don't mess it up.
Yeah!
Oh my god, okay, never mind.
This is so bad.
Thank you.
Flash!
Oh, get up, get up, get up, steak, get up!
Please, please, please, please.
I have to like, run, you know?
I have to like, I have to just keep going.
So that's why it's easier to do the stun grenade.
Just flash!
Bang!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Get up, get up.
Yeah.
Run, run, run.
Flash!
Bang!
Ouch, ouch.
Flash!
Oh, ouch.
No, no, no.
Flash!
B-B-B-B-B-B-B-Bang!
Okay, now we can go to the farmers.
Up this way.
Oh, here, here, here, here.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Why are you so bad?
Ah!
Oh my god.
We're all gonna come after me!
Get outside!
Snake, please.
Snake, run.
Just run.
Snake, just run!
Just run, Snake!
So much for saving my throat.
Stop shooting!
Stop!
Stop it, you freak!
You freak!
I'm gonna drink my hair, my hair, my cat's hair.
I'm gonna drink my tea even though it has a cat's hair in
it.
Ouch.
Are we okay?
Ooh.
There wasn't so much cat hair.
It was like two pieces.
I love my cat.
I'd probably eat my cat's hair all the time.
Call it a minty.
What does that mean?
Oh.
Okay.
What a thrill that was.
Oh, absolutely.
I made it to the roof.
Must be exhausted, Snake.
There was no big deal.
Snake, I'm monitoring you closely.
Your heart rate is elevated and your breathing is shallow.
What's the matter, Snake?
You out of shape from all that dog mushing.
Oh, look at you smiling.
Like you could fucking do that, Colonel.
Wow!
Shut up, Colonel.
You jerk.
Master Miller!
Um, master?
It's fine.
He's probably, like, going to the bathroom, you know?
He's fine.
Yeah, Colonel should not be talking.
Gather ye rosebuds while you may.
Old time is still a-flying.
And this same flower that smiles today, tomorrow will be
dying.
Snake laughter is the best medicine.
You should be happy you've got enough free time to play a
game.
Thanks, Malik.
Wait, I forgot Otacon.
Otacon, I'm up on the roof.
I'm up on the roof.
That was a pretty fast climb.
Oh, yeah.
I wanted to go slowly, but someone there forced me to move
faster.
Someone or like 10 ones.
Well, you can relax because there's an elevator in Tower B.
Yippee!
That walkway will take you to Tower B.
And surely that will be a really easy elevator ride as well.
Surely.
I only have one ration left.
Ah!
That
scared me so much.
Oh my god, Snake!
Snake!
Damn!
Oh no.
I'm afraid I can't let you get past me.
Liquid.
You're not going any far.
Die!
No!
Time for another fight.
With a hind-y.
Oh, well, not yet, actually.
It's a long way down.
If I had a rope.
You do!
I should be able to use that rope I got.
Yes.
What are you going to do?
Take on a hind with your bare hands.
Now you're mine.
If I stay here, I'm finished.
Use the rope!
Uh, I don't remember actually how I did this part.
Here we go.
Come on!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Punch the chopper.
Oh gosh.
Colonel, can you help me?
Help
me!
What do I do?
Here's how to repel.
Thank you.
the X button to jump away okay while you're away from the
wall press down on the directional button to drop down okay
if you jump while pressing right or left on the directional
button big jump you can make a big jump in that direction
okay if you press and hold the circle while using the
directional button you can walk slowly across the wall if
you're careful with the timing you should be able to dodge
the gunfire from behind while you repel down if anyone can
do it You can't, Snake.
Yeah, you wanna make fun of me again?
Huh?
About...
Okay.
Wee!
Oh my god.
Oh, I got hit.
Oh my god, I forgot the steam too.
Ah!
Don't go into the steam, Snake.
Don't go into the steam.
Oh my god.
Ouch.
Here.
Don't get...
Don't get.
Oh, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm trying to avoid stuff.
Oh my god.
Avoid the fire.
And then the steam.
Snake.
Please, Snake.
Snake!
Snake just go down!
Go down!
Snake, go down!
Hit every steam and fire.
Got it.
Oh my gosh.
How did I manage that?
I don't even know.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, that's right.
The door is frozen.
Wait, is this the one that I can blow up with the C2?
Nope, no, don't equip that.
Is this the one that I can blow up?
Or do I have to wait for that?
Red, red, red.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Uh, red, red, red, red.
Hold on.
You guys down there, don't look at me right now.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, did I say seed?
I meant seed more.
Oh, gosh.
Sorry.
I'm a little...
A little...
Shocked after all of that, you know?
A lot just happened, everybody.
Okay, a lot just happened.
So, okay.
Oh, gosh.
I'm just looking for more rations.
Don't mind me.
C2 is called Gias.
I think you're right.
My brain got a little steamed.
I can't believe.
I was...
I don't even know what the hell I was doing there.
Sea floor Floor Wait Sea floor Wait that would also imply
that there's a sea ceiling A sea wall What's wrong with me
today?
Two Thank you Although star 2 was delayed around the time
MGS was being developed It would be going to affect 2000
Star 3 however we scrapped and replaced with in 2003.
Oh.
I know I'm like, maybe this is pointless.
But I'm just gonna check anyway.
I'm a careful person, okay?
Oh, see?
There were some stuff I could grab.
There might be other stuff I can grab.
Who knows?
No turrets?
No turrets yet, you mean?
Oh, wait.
Actually, it's in the other building, isn't there?
Wait, no.
The turrets are in this building.
I don't remember.
Why am I acting like I know everything?
Oh, you're so cruel.
Such a cruel mistress.
If I...
Well, I guess I shouldn't go back up there.
I don't think there was anything else up there, was there?
Well, let's go down to the...
No.
Ah!
It's such a...
Annoying...
Ah!
Uh...
The turrets are in the elevator one?
Ah.
How many?
Oh, I have 11 chaff grenades.
It's not so bad.
Snake is really fit.
He can go up and down so easily.
He's the strongest boy in town.
And if there is a helicopter to fight, he will take it down
with all his might.
He's a solid snake.
He is the greatest soldier in history.
Is that the door?
Yeah.
So calm.
Okay, I'll go.
When's the out of breath codec?
We just had it.
Let's see what they say actually.
Snake, the Hind is still circling above the communications
tower.
No, he's scaring me.
Damn, there's no weapon here that I can use to take him on.
Dr. Emmerich might know where there's a weapon you could use
against the Hind.
Why don't you ask him?
I need Stinger missiles!
Otacon!
Great job!
You made it down!
Yeah.
No problem.
The Stinger missiles are in a small room near the entrance
to the walkway.
Oh.
Okay.
Snake, I'm heading your way.
What are you talking about?
There's something I've got to ask you.
Well, what is it?
Um, well, you see, I...
Oh, I'll ask you when I see you.
Okay!
Bye!
Oh!
That's a death flag.
Master!
Oh, Master!
He's just...
He's got...
He's got stomach issues, you guys.
He can't pick up the phone right now.
Why?
Hmm.
I mean, if I just Nikita missile them, you think they can
take a missile to the face?
Let's just snipe them.
I think that'll be easier.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I only have a three to Zizip hands, though.
Oh, oh,
goodness.
Oh my god.
This is the first time I've ever seen the bullets fly!
Kinga man.
I forgot that my ration.
I forgot to equip my ration.
Anyway.
I know why I said C2.
Because it was C2 of the C4s.
You get it?
Soldier got aim bots.
Yeah, how the hell did he hit me?
From so far away.
Crazy.
Crazy, crazy.
Okay, I'm gonna take out this guy.
Then we're gonna take out the next guy.
This should all be the same height.
Come out.
Oh, where?
Oh, yeah, come here.
Come on.
Okay.
That's it, right?
Yeah.
And there's...
Okay.
Yippee!
What if I didn't have the health to survive that shot?
You know?
What if I didn't have the health for it?
Where am I?
Oh, I'm in the other tower, right?
So now...
We have to worry about the guy.
The...
Now we have to worry.
Oh!
There's the elevator.
Beep!
Wait.
Huh?
Watch him, daisies.
I'm just... I might have watched it already.
But I don't maybe not remember the name.
Oh, sorry.
I instinctually go to Master Miller Snake, I'm heading your
way What are you talking about?
There's something I've got to ask you Well, what is it?
Um, well, you see I'll ask you when I see you Bye Bye Wait a
minute Interesting It looks like Liquid really wants to have
a showdown with you I'm looking at That's not even fair.
Why does he want to have a showdown in a helicopter?
I hope everyone's enjoying the live broadcast.
Snake, I don't like it.
Please don't go up to the roof.
I have to.
I can't run from this one.
I'm enjoying it.
Yippee!
Alrighty.
But...
Why am I going down?
I can't remember this part at all.
Sorry, like I said, I always forget about the Hein-D fight.
Like, so I always forget what to do here.
Colonel, thanks for this super chat.
It's only going up the thing up here, so...
The Hein-D... part.
Oh!
Damn!
Damn.
Time to go back up.
J nice.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Huh?
Oh!
Don't shoot!
Oh.
It's me!
Don't shoot!
Oh my gosh.
How'd you get here?
Well, that wasn't as dramatic as your entrance.
Believe me, I'm afraid of heights.
You were watching?
Yeah, I was watching.
I was riding in the back of their truck.
He was watching the whole time.
Thanks to the stealth camouflage.
Baby Corny, thanks to the five- It's in.
The elevator, of course.
Oh, that's why I couldn't take you.
The first floor of the circular staircase was destroyed.
Yeah.
That's why I took the elevator.
The elevator was working?
Yeah, that's right.
okay you're incredible like a movie hero or something i know
stop no you're wrong he's so obsessed with me the movies the
hero always saves the girl you mean merrill stop snake it's
not your fault sorry forget i said anything snake there's
something i've really got to ask you it's why followed you
up this far oh my god have
you ever loved someone that's what you came to ask no I mean
I I was wondering if even soldiers fall in love what are you
trying to say I want to ask you do you think love can bloom
even on a battlefield yeah I think at any time any place
people can fall in love with each other but if you love
someone you have to be able to protect them I think so too I
have a favor to ask uh-oh don't worry it'll be easy I told
you before I don't want to hurt anyone I don't want you to
either okay the elevator is so cute I want you to get it to
move you see that's weird it was working before but now it
isn't that is weird maybe the panel's broken can you fix it
it was working before if it's the mechanism leave it to me
we're leaving it to you i've got to go and swat a noisy fly
some bothersome flies i'll stay here and hold the fort gosh
they really are brothers you really look like hell are you
okay don't worry if i do this it doesn't matter i just
pretend like i'm not here Then I'm not scared little baby
strange logic.
I'm counting on you
Gosh when he stands still I really can't see him
Bye-bye Bye-bye Otacon sweet little baby
Okay, now we can go oh Oh Ha, ha, ha, I remembered, I
remembered, I remembered.
Ha, ha, ho.
Mmm, you.
You.
Stinger time on these?
Can I use, oh, I can't use the Nikita.
I only have six bullets, though.
Mmm.
I think I might just chaff it, and I think maybe each chaff
I can go up two staircases, I imagine.
I have a lot more chaffs than I have Stinger, and I'm gonna
need the Stinger for the next fight, so.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run.
Oh.
Heck.
Oh my god.
It didn't even have any!
What a con, Shadow, What was this hard to see?
Champion 2005.
Oh, come on!
Go, go, go!
Oh, I'm just gonna do this again.
That's fine.
This part is so goofy.
There's three of them.
We'll blow up the cameras as our last resort.
But I think this is better.
since I have a lot of them.
I have a lot of chaff grenades and
and so I think it's better to do it like this.
Oh,
come on.
Come on, Snake.
Not that it matters.
Not that it matters because there won't be any more until
it's they literally oh wait they literally why is the angle
like this oh we're good see why is it why is it so tight my
goodness
we did it and we got more chop grenades thank you
perfect that's what she said oh my god She said also that we
got more chaff grenades?
Oh, there we go.
What a thrill.
Wrong game.
Hum, hum, hum.
There's nothing over here, right?
Yeah.
Hum, hum, hum.
Oh, wrong button.
What's up, Snake?
The security advisor for this building takes a puff of
cigarette and on the third floor there will be three cameras
it's true in paradise lost milton wrote solitude sometimes
is best society and short retirement urges sweet return is
that why you came back snake you got tired of your short
retirement in alaska huh i don't know about that I was
forcefully...
I was kidnapped, Malink.
I was forcefully brought here.
They didn't give me a choice.
Liquid is still hovering around the roof of Tower B.
He's waiting for you.
Snake, it's time for you to take him on.
Take him on and take him out.
Master, do you have any wisdom for me before I fight?
No, okay.
Meryl, how about you?
None, okay.
How to Khan?
on that elevator you're gonna go after that hind now yeah I
can still hear the sound of its rotors it's just circling
the tower man yeah well you won't hear it for much longer
good in the meantime I'll fix the elevator so you can use it
later thank you let's hear what Nostasia has to say she's
gonna be like in the 50s you have a stinger missiles now you
have a chance against the hind Only a chance.
Oh.
Well, you are not exactly evenly armed.
That's true.
That hind is a monster.
You have only a small chance to win, but at least it's
better than no chance.
No chance.
That's a pretty grim analysis, Nostasha.
To shoot down that hind, you will have to get to a place
with good visibility.
Do not try to fight him in that walkway.
Get up on that roof where you will have a clean shot at him.
Okay.
All right.
I don't know how this fight's going to go, but we shall see.
see we got four rations but our life is a little we little
not so good if I think in one hit we'll be oh wait we'll be
dead in one hit but you know so the snakes finally come out
of his home my brother don't yeah don't call me brother but
better what what the father that's the father that you I'll
send you to hell to meet him.
All right.
Gosh, that was a close one.
Oh, wait.
How do I...
Wait.
Oh, my gosh.
X button.
Okay.
Oh, there are rations over here, though.
Okay, I'll save those for later.
X button?
You guys, I was thinking, like, X?
I'm using like a, what's it called, controller, AM.
Oh, I can't grab them.
Come here.
Come here, stop being so sneaky.
Get, come here.
Face me like a man.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Eee, go!
Da-da-da-da-da-da-dun-dun-dun-jum.
X!
Oh, just one.
Oh my gosh.
He hit so hard.
Oh, he went the wrong way.
Oh, I thought he was going to go the other way.
Yeah!
I might need to go grab.
Oh, how do we get up here?
Wait, how many do I have?
Yeah, let's just grab these.
So we can fill up.
Oh,
no.
I managed that.
I don't know.
That's crazy.
Oh, nope.
Let's go over here.
Ah!
Actually, I'm gonna go...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I don't know.
He's on this side.
Oh!
I got him still!
Yippee!
Oh!
Don't keep shooting.
Stop shooting!
Oh my god.
Unfair.
You can't just keep shooting at me!
Hello?
Aim?
Stinger missile?
Hello?
Oh, okay, that's why.
I'm just gonna blow this thing up eventually.
stop stop stop stop stop oh what it did such a little damage
even though it was like so in his face what just happened oh
he's doing that below are we in phase two
ouchy ouchy I
can't see
Oh my gosh, no way.
This one's gonna...
This one's gonna take a while, you guys, unfortunately, I
think.
Or rather, a couple tries, I'd say.
I have no more rations.
I don't think there's any over here, are there?
No.
Fuck!
That's so unfair!
How am I supposed to dodge,
though?
Oh my god.
It's just gonna hit the walls again.
This part is so annoying.
Oh!
bury it.
Yeah, you're right.
What am
I...
I have to, like, guess where he's gonna be at.
Hmm?
He was the sword.
So he'll probably, like, come up around...
Around over here, right?
It's gone.
Oh!
Oh, gosh.
Yeah, I don't think...
this is, I don't think this is the, this is not the run, but
that's okay.
Can the box counter the Heinz missiles?
My box?
Like, my cardboard box?
It's okay.
Like I said, I knew this one would be...
Still annoying, though.
Oh, oh, whoops.
There we go.
Still annoying, though.
How
did I dodge that?
Are you frustrated, brother?
Which way is he going?
This way?
Yeah.
Thought he was gonna go the other way.
Okay.
Goodness gracious.
How fast do I need to be when he comes up is my thing.
No body armor?
I don't have any.
I don't have any, but I never picked it up.
I don't even remember where it's at.
That's okay.
Oh, wait.
He's here.
Oh, this is that part.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
So shoot once he comes up, but after he shoots.
Oh, come on.
That's so unfair.
Yippo!
Okay.
So, like, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Ah!
Oh, it wasn't fast enough.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, sir.
Sir, sir, sir.
Please, please.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, I'm not fast enough.
I don't think.
Wait, how many?
I have 10?
Let's grab this while we're here.
This is so unfair.
No!
Oh my god, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop!
Snake!
You scare me sometimes, Snake.
You scare me sometimes, man.
You scare me a lot.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, okay.
Now he's back below.
I hate when he's over there.
It's really hard to shoot him from there.
Oh!
Nice and nice.
Ha ha ha ha.
Slow and steady, I suppose.
What was that?
Like,
I shot him, but I didn't.
He's just yelling.
He's just yelling into the void.
Oh, Liquid, you're so silly.
Silly guy.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, he's gonna come up any second now.
No?
Okay, just kidding.
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh, oh shoot.
Ah!
Nice.
Using that radar.
Oh my gosh, that was fast.
That's me fighting you!
So, it
was, that was my bad.
I knew, I instinctually pressed it.
I knew I shouldn't have, though.
Oh my goodness.
Come on, come on out.
I wonder what the speedrun strat for this is, because
there's no way that you're just supposed to stand here and
wait for him, right?
That feels crazy.
They skip it?
Strat is to punch the chopper, obviously.
you can shoot him from the edge of the rails you can i'm too
afraid of it blowing up in my face though so i will not do
that i'm too afraid of it literally exploding on top of me i
knowing me i'll miss somehow you know that's just how it is
mental gaming
oh Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I don't mean to get hit there.
Okay.
Um, can I hit you now?
Can I get you now?
Yeah!
Oh, dang it.
Dang it.
I missed my chance.
Oh, I missed my chance.
Well, that's frustrating!
Run,
run, run, run, don't miss your chance!
Mr. Fontown!
Oh, why did I...
I... I...
How many missiles?
Okay, I only have six.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
I'm starting to throw, I'm starting to throw.
I'm starting to throw you guys.
Oh my gosh.
Do I have enough to beat him?
More missiles will spawn, right?
If I can't beat him with these, I'll have to use like Nikita
or something.
Wouldn't that be something?
Let's get more quick.
I only have five left.
I don't have six.
We'll get more once you run out.
He went back under too fast.
I was too slow.
Skill issue.
Something, something.
You
for being such a coward, you're the one in a helicopter.
Why do you keep having to go under?
Huh?
Why do you keep hiding yourself?
Where are you?
Oh, there you are!
Wait a second!
Wait, do I need one more?
Oh, his propellers are really slow.
Yippee!
It's exploding liquid!
It's on fire!
Wow, he's so cool, he's just like an action hero.
Otakon's watching from the door.
He's like peeking from the door.
He's like, wow.
That takes care of the cremation.
What a loser.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yay!
The feet hindee!
Snake, the elevator's working.
Yay!
No, that's the weird thing.
by itself okay it's headed your way now is that so okay that
explosion before what was it oh i had to take out that
helicopter helicopter that's incredible snake listen i just
want to make sure again this is the way to get to where
metal gear is being stored yeah the entrance to the
underground maintenance base is towards the back of the snow
field ahead okay find a safe place to hide out I'm just
gonna say your Thank you, thank you too Is the absolute
cutest thing ever Might be the best alert stream Of all time
You think so?
Tell me if you need to Thanks I mean, thank you, thank you
That should make some new ones Those are old ones That
should make some new ones, right?
Okay Nice Nice We did it!
Only took two tries.
And we have three rations left.
And Otacon said I'm incredible.
I believe in, um, you know.
Uh, Psycho Mantis.
He said that I was a gamer.
He said I was a gamer.
I do wonder what I'll get this time.
Probably.
I think at last.
I think we'll get it.
Before I got elephant, I'll probably get elephant again.
If I had to guess, if I had to guess, I'll probably get it
again.
Wait, where do I go?
I just go downstairs?
Why is it in Japanese?
Because I'm playing integral.
So, um, yeah.
Oh, it's all worth it to hear Otakon compliment you.
I know that's what I'm saying.
Do I have to use my chaffs again?
Okay.
I guess we'll get our answer in a second.
Oh, yes, I do.
Uh-huh.
Or I could use my stinger missiles because...
But it only shoots...
Look at both.
Yay!
I only have one...
One ammo left.
Oh, it'll show me the camera.
Splash damage.
Nikita.
I think from here, Nikita would be okay.
In fact.
I mean, I know I'll get Stinger Missile ammo later on again,
but Oh, I can't use the Nikita.
Oh, I think because the radar doesn't work, right?
It's all blocked, so...
I'll just chaff.
I got more.
Wait.
Oh, dang it.
It's so close.
I think that's the last one because it's only one, right?
Yes.
That's the last one.
I guess we could have shot that one, actually.
Aw.
Ida-Kan.
You left me a bunch of presents.
How'd you know that bullets were my favorite food?
Okay, let's call?
I don't know why, but the elevator just started working
again.
If you take it all the way to the bottom of Tower B and go
outside, you'll be in the snowfield.
Yes.
The entrance to the underground maintenance base is in the
north of the snowfield.
Oh, she sounds a little... why you sound a little nervous
about that?
You did it, Snake.
You shot down behind.
One, Stinger Missile's worth, like, 200k USD, and he was
exempted to destroy Walmart now.
Just because we've taken out their leader doesn't mean
they're going to give up.
They're still going to try to launch that nuke.
You're right.
There's no time to waste.
Hurry.
The underground base is past the communications tower.
The elevator's working again, isn't it?
Yeah.
Oh.
Master?
No response.
Nostasha.
I know.
Well, after all, that Hein shot down two F-16s.
It is hard to believe that after doing that, it got taken
out by just one man.
I'm not just one man.
I'm a superman.
man not copyright now yeah i'm so great i'm like kind of
awesome oh okay let's go in here i'm gonna equip my gun just
in case i don't think anything's gonna happen i'm just you
know
oh i just you know
Huh?
Body armor is in the blast furnace.
Wait, it's where?
Because I do want it eventually.
It's in the blast furnace or back of the gas filled rooms.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Um, cool.
I will go back there.
Huh?
Um, Otacon, you said it was working.
I don't know why, but the elevator- No, it's not!
It's not working!
Oh, it's working!
Just kidding.
I lied.
I'm a liar.
Snake, there's something I forgot to tell you before.
What's that?
What?
There were five stealth camouflage prototypes in my lab.
And one of them should have been mine.
So, if you take out the one I'm wearing, that leaves four.
Yeah?
This isn't first grade math class.
I thought I'd get one for you.
So I went back to the lab and...
Spit it out already!
Yeah.
The four suits were missing.
Uh-huh.
Also, about the elevator that I checked out.
It's really strange.
It was like someone was intentionally holding it.
When you were riding on it, did the weight limit warning go
off?
That's another thing that bothered me about it.
The warning went off and I know I couldn't be over the
limit.
How much do you weigh?
About 135.
Skinny legend.
But that elevator had a weight limit of 650 pounds.
It would take at least five people.
Look out, Snake.
The guys who stole my stealth prototypes are in there with
you.
Oh, my God!
Too late, Snake.
Now die.
Wait, hold on.
There we go.
Yeah!
Why
are you guys so fast?
Why are you guys so fast?
How are you still alive?
How are you guys still alive?
Oh, ouchy.
Ouch.
Who's hitting you?
me oh my god oh there we go oh my god one of them gave me a
ration nice oh are you still still alive how are you still
alive are
you dead now finally oh chokehold's better you know it's
fine then i got all these bullets i gotta use them
I only use like half.
Then we got a free ration out of it.
Well, that was exciting, wasn't it?
More chuff, more chuff, more chuff.
Why does it feel like if this was MGS3, there would be a
little frog in there for me to shoot?
You know what I mean?
Oh, another ration.
Nice.
Yeah, little kerosan.
Okay.
Oh, I almost just died.
I almost just died for real.
I know.
I almost just died.
Holy cow!
This is so unfair.
Oh, you scared the shit.
I'm sorry.
If only we can aim like Twin Sigs.
I know, right?
I wish.
Okay, I chaff.
Wonder why they're giving me so much sniper ammo.
Oh, run, run, run, run, run, run!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go go go snake, go snake, go snake, go snake.
Ah!
God!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Wait!
Oh my god, there's more!
Just go, just go.
We're fine.
Whoa.
It's pitch darkness.
Can I
see anything if I use the sniper?
Oh, I can.
Oh, that's actually pretty cool.
I don't remember if I Nakeda Missiled this last time or if I
properly did the fight, but...
I might just Nakeda Missile.
I don't know.
We'll see.
We might do a mix of both.
Who knows?
Codec 140.66.
Oh.
140.
There we go.
Yay, music channel!
We got the other one in the first stream.
Thank you guys for telling me about these.
They're so cool.
Nice.
Okay.
It looks like the weather is getting worse.
Try using your binoculars.
Oh, yeah.
What about the satellite data?
I'm sorry, Snake.
I can't see the entrance in the satellite photos either.
Yikes.
What about a heat source?
An exhaust pipe or something?
I can't confirm anything.
Only that there are multiple heat sources to the southeast
of your position.
That's probably just the burning wreckage from behind.
Snake, you're in a big open space surrounded by walls.
The entrance to the underground base should be somewhere in
there.
Somewhere in there.
Stay close to the walls and you won't get lost.
Okay.
Snake, you're our only hope.
Please stop them from launching that nuke.
Okay.
Snake just stares at the music.
I know it's so funny.
Otacon, which direction is the underground base?
It's in the snowfield to the north of Tower B.
The door is security level six.
The weather's terrible.
Make sure you don't get lost out there.
Snake, I hear dogs.
But it's bitter cold out there.
It'd be dangerous to stay out in the snowfield too long.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
He's back!
Ah!
Master!
You're recovered from your RBS.
It may look pretty at first, but it'll severely limit your
disability.
Master's back!
Be careful!
Yummy!
Alright, let's get this over with.
But also, is there anything around here?
through a couple of rations so lucky me
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh there snake are you okay I'm
fine Aura-con were there any other stealth prototypes no
there were only five so this isn't stealth camouflage then
what are you talking about someone's aiming at me in the
middle of this blizzard it's her wolf sniper wolves sniper
Yes, it's her.
It's definitely her.
Otakon, you sound like you're happy.
He's smiling.
He's cheesing.
So then what is it?
Oh, his glasses.
Please don't kill her.
Are you insane?
Please.
Master Rose back up to her body for his life, not the
toilet.
Listen to me, kid.
She's a merciless killer.
I can see you perfectly.
Oh, she's so hot.
Look at her.
I told you, I never quit.
the hunt now you're mine now you're mine no you can't don't
get between a wolf and his brain you're pretty good if you
can hit me in this storm you see women naturally make better
soldiers wolf don't do this snake i'm near catch your sense
here it's a mistake for a sniper to her vocal fry so sexy
though is that right well I'm going to send you a love
letter my dear do you know what that is it's a bullet
straight from my gun to your heart please wolf snake no
quiet stay don't get in our way now I'm gonna pay you back
for Merrill you men are so weak you could never finish what
you start that's what I'm about to do it's literally what I
just said I was gonna do?
Okay.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh, gosh.
La, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba.
Okay, um, there's, like, this truck up here.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
This maybe is a bad idea.
Oh, um, okay, never mind.
Anyway, uh, uh, let's just leave over here and, um, get
down.
Dun, dun, dun.
If I just...
Okay, first...
I'm gonna find her.
Where's she at?
Where are you at, girl?
Oh, there you are.
Okay.
That one
doesn't count, you guys.
That one doesn't count.
That's so silly.
Oh my goodness gracious.
That one doesn't count.
I don't actually remember how I did this before.
I think I like hid behind like here or something.
Oh!
Oh gosh.
That even looks different which is so cool.
Like where, depending on where I'm at.
That's so awesome.
Snake, are you okay?
Can I skip all of this?
Were there any other stealth prototypes?
You, you, where you are.
I'm near.
Oh, shoot, man.
I mean, don't shoot, man.
I never even got...
I never even...
Wait, did this spot a new ration?
Yippee!
Okay, all right.
I'm gonna shoot Nikita.
What if I shoot it from like here?
Can I not shoot it?
Like, oh.
Is that her?
Yep.
Okay, I have to find a way.
Explode it to me.
Oh, because I un-equipped it.
That's so cool.
Let's find a way around.
Maybe.
Wait, so she can't hit me.
Oh, there is no way around.
Interesting.
Okay, but she can't hit me while this is, like, going.
So, if I just, um, get up here.
Ouch.
If I even can.
Oh my god.
Don't hit me.
You can go uphill if you've got speed.
I don't know why the sniper missions are giving me so much
trouble when literally those were the easiest for me before.
I can't even climb, crawl up this.
Run, run, run,
run, run, run, but I gotta be like super speed.
I gotta be like the speediest ever.
Snake, come on.
I don't think I have a lot of daisizipan.
Yeah, I don't have a lot.
Uh-oh.
Gosh, I don't even know where she's...
This is such a terrible location.
I don't even...
Oh, oh.
Stinger her, it won't let you.
It even says...
They don't work as well, though.
They work, but they don't work as well.
Hmm.
Maybe I just, like, stick around back here and kind of...
Oh, no.
I can't see anything from back here.
Oh, a little bit.
A little bit.
Actually, a lot of it.
I might be able to do it from over here.
If I run it.
Or if I...
How fast do I have to be?
Then Akita can go up from there.
the sides.
A cat?
I don't believe you.
From the right little mountain?
These?
Like, this?
Like, if I shoot it right here, it'll go up.
The mountain.
Try it out.
You know what?
I will try.
Sorry.
I accidentally unequipped it.
I've been having that problem all day where I keep pressing
R1 to view in first person instead of triangle.
Okay, I won't unequip it.
Oh, shit.
Not that way.
What are you talking?
Wait, what are we talking about then?
Wait, okay, hold on.
Oh, it went over.
Okay, okay, okay.
We can do it from here.
It worked!
Oh, can I get her right now?
Wait, she's waiting for me!
You bitch!
She's a monster.
How did she live?
Well, I just wasted one, but we can maybe get her with the
amount.
You know, actually, I think I can start the cutscene.
There we go.
Snake, are you okay?
I'm not okay, actually.
I'm really scared at how she didn't die to that.
I'm actually quite scared.
Okay, sorry.
This is an annoying one to skip, isn't it?
I think I, like, literally first tried her last time, so...
another thought okay oh there we
go nice
enemy that's so cute you don't see it coming do you she's
running you
she got me you guys oh I can use the stinger I I don't know
why I want to go maybe
go up the side go up the side adjust oh this is so this is
so no you guys this is not this is not gonna work this is
not gonna work for me oh man this is not gonna work for me
where is she where is she at where is she not where are you
come out please
medicine where where the hell cyber wolves not being a
coward what the oh
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh i can't move i can't move i saw her aiming
at me though from where maybe she's over this
hello wouldn't you move if you can't see me Oh my god, I'm
so shaky.
I'm nervous.
Oh, ah!
I know!
I wasted my whole disapairam!
Because of you.
Get her, get her face, get her face!
I'm gonna get her arm.
Okay, that doesn't work.
Sure, sure, sniper wall, sure.
Oh my god.
Finally!
Good lord.
Wasting so much Ah, ah, ah, ah.
I just need so much ammo.
Cigarettes, please.
Save me.
Oh, no way.
But if I get hit again, I'll die.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, hold on.
This is not good.
Stop!
Stop running!
There we go.
I could still hit her.
I'm just a little shaky.
I'm just a little rusty, you guys.
I'm just a little...
I'm looking...
I'm looking directly at a beautiful woman.
Of course I would be so...
I would be so nervous of course not even a desert pam can
help me here you guys I'm I'm I'm yeah that's right I'm I'm
I'm hopeless I'm hopeless I'm just I'm just a snake in love
snakes don't even have hands so you know what give me credit
just grew these okay oh I almost got her I only have three
bullets at and then I'm gonna have to run and get up more.
Come on, Wolf.
Come here.
I mean...
Wolf.
Wolfie Wolf.
Yeah.
I'm gaming!
Oh, God.
We're gaming without the dice, Pam.
No, sheesh.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I thought I'd...
Okay.
I think it's time for me to run.
We'll go back to that.
spot in a second after I grab some ammo.
Ammo!
Okay, only five.
That's fine.
I don't mind.
I think there was some more up here.
Yep.
Okay, thank you.
I'm back in position now.
Okay, where'd you at?
Where'd you go?
Where'd you go, pretty lady?
Don't shoot at me.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, controller this way, controller, this way,
controller, this way.
Oh, gosh, you know what?
I'm gonna use the rations, and then I'm gonna go to the
cigarettes.
There we go.
Okay.
Come here.
Come here, pretty lighty.
I'm kind of a genius.
Oh, gosh.
The cigarettes don't help very much, you guys.
so close oh my god they don't help very much at all anybody
who says that they help so much is a liar oh i was right in
position please i got look at me and my smokes prevail in
the rematch against sniper wolf yippee
no the first one didn't count you guys the first one didn't
count i don't remember even oh how How did I die?
I don't even remember.
Oh, let me go straight to her.
Cutscene time.
I want to explore a little.
Oh no.
I'm gonna be so sad.
I...
waited for this moment.
I am a sniper.
Waiting is my job.
Never moving a muscle.
trading
I am long shot you cannot save me I did that gosh I'm sorry
please just finish me quick I am occurred I have always
dreamed of a peaceful place like this this is nice place to
die so that's why you're called wolf I was born on the
battlefield raised on the battlefield gunfire sirens and
screams they were my lullabies hunted like dogs day after
day driven from our ragged shelters that was my life
Each morning I'd wake up and find a few more of my family or
friends still beside me.
I stare at the morning sun and pray to make it through the
day.
The governments of the world turned a blind eye to our
misery.
But then he appeared.
Big Boss.
My hero.
Saladin.
He took me away from all that.
Saladin?
You mean big boss?
I became a sniper.
Hidden.
Salad, man.
Watching everything through a rifle scope.
Now I could see war.
Not from inside, but from the outside.
as an observer I watched the reality the stupidity stop
ruining the scene I joined this group of revolutionaries to
take my revenge on the world but I have shame in myself and
my people.
Big Boss really likes snipers, isn't he?
I am no longer the wolf I was born to be.
In the name of vengeance, I sought my body and my soul.
Wolves are noble animals.
They're not like dogs.
It's been an article I posted in that I guess...
On Yupik, the word for wolf is Keglenek.
The Aluts revere them as honorable cousins.
They call mercenaries like us dogs of war.
It's true.
We're all for sale at some price or another.
You're different.
Untamed.
Solitary.
You're no dog.
You're a wolf.
No way!
Who are you?
He takes such like...
Are you Saladin?
He's so compassionate even for the other team, you know.
You spared Merrill's life.
She... she was never my real daughter.
I don't kill for sport.
Rest easy.
You'll die as the proud wolf you are.
I finally understand.
I wasn't waiting to kill people.
I was waiting for someone to kill me.
A man like you.
You're a hero.
Please, set me free.
I
love you.
What is it?
My gun.
Give it to me.
Don't trip.
She's part of me.
Everyone's here now.
now it's probably best that she doesn't care about otaka you
know just just be more painful for him
snake you said that love could bloom on the battlefield but
I couldn't save her what are you doing
turning it to its owner.
I don't need a handkerchief.
I don't have any more tears to shed.
I'm going to the underground base.
We're out of time.
I know.
You'll have to protect yourself now.
Don't trust anyone.
Yeah.
If I can't stop Metal Gear, this whole place will probably
be bombed to hell.
Yeah.
We might not meet again.
No.
I'll hang on to my codec.
No!
I want to keep helping.
You can leave anytime.
Sweet boy.
Get a head start.
A head start on your new life.
How is he supposed to leave?
This part is so good.
Snake!
What was she fighting for?
What am I fighting for?
What are you fighting for?
If we make it through this, I'll tell you.
Okay.
I'll be searching too.
You have to ruin the auto cards, but this is stupid.
Okay.
Ugh.
That scene gets me everything.
time you guys man it's a bad if i say i was reminded of the
barking noises every time everyone wait barking noises
everyone made it off-clive when hearing the wolves howl just
now shut up no no okay i have no more tears to shed i'm just
like snake i'm not crying i'm fine i'm not crying you're
crying Baby, wait, what is it?
Oh, seven.
Oh, gosh, she scared me.
It's kind of like, it's, it's...
Even with her... I think with her face covered, it's even
scarier, you know?
How many tissues did it take?
So, only that angle right there.
This one.
I like that we can't see Snake's face, though.
A little dramatic, you know.
Yeah, I...
I...
I remember you!
Okay, hold on.
Oh, I need to have my key to open it.
Okay.
Slip inside.
Oh wait, it doesn't matter, I'm crouched, so...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, no.
More disabound.
Stun grenade, ration.
Oh, look, you can see them.
That's so cool.
I never noticed you were able to.
Oh, gosh.
Snake out.
I thought...
Wait, I thought I wasn't full.
I just looked.
Oh, wait.
Those are the clay mort.
I was looked at the C4, my bad.
it.
I can't trust anything.
Lots of bullets.
We have these old graphics in there, right?
Where do we see, um, behind D?
Oh!
What's in there, though?
Go to
the Do
I go up here?
Can I see it from...
Oh my god, mistake.
Just climb.
Like from here?
Yeah, I'm checking.
Press against the wall?
With the tree in view.
This tree?
It's so specific, right?
Ah!
There it is.
Colonel, listen to me.
I found a parachute near the wreckage of the Hive.
Dun, dun!
A parachute?
You don't think that Liquid survived?
Impossible.
As soon as he jumped out of the pilot seat, he'd be sliced
up faster than an onion on an infomercial.
That is true.
So what's that parachute doing there then?
I have no idea.
A trap?
Either that or a message to me.
Meaning I'm not dead, I suppose.
But I think it's more like I'll string you up.
Ooh, wow.
Well, in any case, don't let your car down.
Naomi had nothing to say about that.
I won't.
Naomi was just like, uh, no comment, Snake.
Why did you say it like that?
No comment.
Okay.
Nothing here.
Is this a fast travel truck?
Okay, before we go in here, there's the one with the camera
room.
I think this is also a camera room.
Yep.
What's in here, though?
Oh.
Eh.
What are those?
I can't tell.
Oh, gosh.
I still don't know what type of bullet stuff is.
Hmm.
Okay, there's like a slight window of opportunity.
Oh my gosh.
Don't scare me like that.
Oh, Nakita missile.
Oh, I should probably have mine just in case.
It's so quiet.
Wait, but before it like looked out the room, you see that?
like it like had the whole thing open oh there we go oh my
gosh
we're fine i didn't go in here right oh this is where we're
supposed to go oh oh then what was this one down here this
one we can go into rations and uh something i'm just gonna
chaff i give up i give up
i don't care what rank i get oh wait uh so it's okay you
don't have to keep commenting she's gonna get blah blah blah
rank it's totally fine i don't really care i don't care
about stuff like that but thanks for your concern we got the
next box and this one oh nope
chaffs chaff chaff grenade grenade grenade okay we got it
all let's get the heck out of here Okay, now we can go,
though.
Beep!
We care a lot.
Well, then you can discuss it amongst yourselves and...
Not in my chat.
Thank you, Mars.
Oh, yeah.
Chaff.
Oh.
Boo!
Toxic streamer.
Disc 2!
Press the 3 thingy...
Okay.
That was all Disc 1?
Yeah!
But Disc 2 is shorter, you know.
I wish I could headshot people.
Okay.
From here, I gotta go down.
I wonder if I can knock and get him over.
I wonder if I can choke him.
Come here.
Oh my god.
Oh, thanks.
I don't need that though.
I'm gonna...
Oh, whoops.
I'm gonna save real quick.
And...
To live ugly and to die beautiful.
I think it's true.
Once you're dead, you'll never have another chance to be
happy.
I can't understand people who want to die before their time.
Please, Snake, promise me that you'll come back alive.
Aww.
I promise.
I promise you, girly.
Where is the body armor?
Oh.
Nothing.
Yikes.
Alright, Campbell.
Snake, that's a blast furnace.
I'm already dead, though, so what am I supposed to do?
What are they used that for?
There's no airport on the base, so it's hard to bring in
supplies.
They must have built a blast furnace so they could make
building materials as such.
That makes sense.
I'm starting to sweat.
It's getting kind of warm.
My OG MGS1 disc was damaged by an earthquake.
Oh, no!
There should be a cargo elevator that you can take down
somewhere around here.
The replacement?
That's so awesome.
Wait, what did he say?
Try to find what?
Uh-oh.
Master, you and I were nothing more than dogs, are we?
That's not like you, Snake.
Don't let what Sniper Wolf said bother you.
Listen, there's not a soldier alive that doesn't question
himself.
And if there is one, he's nothing more than a murderer.
Master's so awesome.
But someone like Wolf, a soldier who's looking for nothing
more than their own death, is no good to anyone either.
Once she started to look for death, it was all over.
That's how you'll end up too, Snake.
Whoa.
There's a cargo elevator in the northeast part of the bottom
floor.
I know.
You can take that to Metal Gear's underground base.
You'll spot it right away.
It's got a big patrol light attached to it.
Okay.
Thanks, AutoCAD.
Oh, wait, no, that's not what I meant to do, Nastasha.
What's up, Snake?
Talk to you later, Snake.
Talk to you later.
Won't that be too loud?
Or is it because it's so loud in here that it would be fine
to take them out?
Wait, is she a genius?
Wait, is she serious?
Wouldn't it be too loud, though?
Seriously?
Where are all the guys, though?
Okay, there's a camera there.
Oh my god.
It's like...
Nastasha, I can't see anything.
Nastasha, okay, there's two cameras.
I know there's guys on the other side, though.
Let's just get up.
What was that news?
Can I even see them from here?
Nastasha?
I don't know what you're talking about, girl.
I hope you like my advice after this mission.
You'll never hear from me again.
It's true.
She writes her book and dips.
Huh?
What was that noise?
Wait, maybe from over here.
Maybe from here.
Nostasha, girl.
What?
Are we playing the same game?
Where do you want me to shoot these guys?
I'm eating floor right now, Nostasia, please.
Okay, whatever.
I thought she was cooking.
I really thought.
Okay.
This guy right here.
Where are they, anyway?
I don't even see the other guys here, actually.
Now that I think about it, there's a guy walking around over
there, isn't there?
Look at the little rats.
Does she mean the cameras?
Everyone's allowed to give a little bad advice as a treat.
Okay, I'm nervous about this one.
I'll be... Oh, there he is!
There he is!
I don't... I thought there were three guys, though.
Okay, I'm nervous about this because, you know, sometimes
the wall and I don't...
really get along.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Sometimes the wall and I don't really get along.
Oh my god, there he is.
He doesn't show up on my radar, which is... Oh, yes he does.
Just kidding.
Is this where I should?
Yes.
Yippee!
Maybe I can do it from here.
I just want to know what her thought process is, truly.
I can do it.
Nostasia.
Nostasia, there's no way.
From the staircase?
Sorry.
I know I keep trying this.
I'm just...
I can't even...
I can't even reach him.
Oh my god.
He doesn't come up the stairs, does he?
Does he even look up the stairs?
I don't know where... Oh, there he is.
You need to be on the stairs.
He's gonna see me, though.
He's gonna see me in my box.
He's about to see me in my box.
He's gonna go, huh?
Just a box.
See?
Oh,
God.
Don't see me.
Don't come this way.
C4.
If he comes this way, we're taking him out.
Is he okay?
What is he doing?
Are you okay, buddy?
You get a little spooked by something?
We have to go inside this elevator to...
Sorry, hold on.
I'm just getting my bigger rings.
To...
For later, I believe.
Is he good?
What is happening?
What's wrong with you?
Oh, shit.
I was gonna go for it, but he...
He came back.
Don't come this way.
What is he doing?
We'll just leave him to his devices.
He's got demons.
He's...
He's dealing with something, you guys.
I don't know what to tell you.
or he's going through it a little bit or something.
Here comes the elevator.
Here it comes.
There it comes.
They're giving me lots of bullets.
I sure hope that this elevator will be a calm, nice,
collected little ride, you know?
Surely this one will be the calm elevator ride.
Oh, the body armor.
Should I get it now or later?
Where is it at?
Because I have to come back here.
I think I could...
Well, I'll win it before Vulcan Raven.
Probably.
You can get it now.
Get it now?
Where is it at?
Can you guys backseat for me?
Okay.
Got a vent?
Inside that vent.
What's a vent?
There's a vent here?
Am I crazy?
There's no vent in this?
Oh my goodness.
In here?
Oh.
Ouch!
I forgot.
Is that it?
I believe they mean the door.
Yeah, that's not a really event, you guys.
PSG.
Unless there's events inside here.
Is that it?
That looks like more bullets.
Somewhere.
Somewhere around here, perhaps.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh?
There's stuff to crawl under.
Okay, hold on.
I'll go back.
Wait, under.
Okay.
There's a marked entrance on the radar.
One that you came in.
Crawl under the pipes on the left side of the room.
Okay, thanks, mod.
Ouch!
Okay.
Wait.
Crawl under the pipes on the left side of the room.
Not the ghost ration, right?
Stun grenade.
Take that.
Wait.
Oh, oh!
Oh, wait, okay, inside here.
Oh, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see.
Oh my god, sorry.
I'm a little slow.
There we go.
Here.
I see, I see, I see.
Okay, hold on.
I gotta scoot out a little bit to stand up and Throw...
Biddle, little, little, little, little, little, little,
little, little, little, bunny armor!
Anything else around here?
Ooh, that's just dope, actually.
More chopper in it, I'll take you.
Okay.
Beep-beep.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay, thanks, guys.
Sorry.
A little slow.
Oh, how did I...
How did I...
Oh my god, it's always this one!
than I anticipate it being, which is why it gets me every
time.
But we're fine.
We're okay.
We're heading back.
We're leaving.
We don't care about those guys.
Okay.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Hoki-doki.
What else was around here?
Anything else?
Don't think so.
Oh, just kidding.
Can I fall here?
Can I fall and die?
I would really be unfortunate, wouldn't I?
No more socom Socom Socom Get out of here, orb Actually,
thanks for being here and doing your job That I totally pay
you To do Um Okie dokie Ike my show Beep BEEP BEEP BEEP BEEP
BEEP BEEP.
Maybe a card?
Card 6.
There we go.
Oh my god no!
This was supposed to be a peaceful elevator ride!
No!
Dun,
dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
Actually, um, actually.
I'm sorry, how did you live my choke?
How did you live my choke?
How did you live?
How did you survive?
Scripted.
That's so scripted.
Oh my god.
Ouch, y'all.
Please.
Please let me get up.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to shoot it.
I'm just holding down.
This is ridiculous.
This is ridiculousness.
Oh!
They died.
I live.
Scale issue, something something.
I hear them.
Aren't there also...
Oh wait, it won't let me use the mind detector.
But aren't there also mines in there?
I think so.
Just avoid them.
Card.
Beep.
Okay, this is the calm one.
Unless...
I want to have a little fun.
Unless I'm a little bit of a freak.
Actually, I can't see anything.
Can I even stipe them?
You know what?
It's fine.
It's probably for the best.
Burr, burr, burr, burr, burr, burr.
Burr, burr, burr, burr.
I punched the bird!
I punched the bird, you guys!
Oh.
Yeah?
Sorry, Master Miller.
I punched a bird.
Oh, okay.
Not about the bird.
Is this conversation secure?
Yes.
Don't worry.
The monitor's off.
Okay.
What's up?
I was in the FBI, too, you know.
Yeah?
I didn't know that.
What's your point?
Why are you so rude to your master?
Doctor, your story about her background, about her
grandfather being an assistant secretary to Hoover and the
FBI?
What are you saying?
Yeah.
And then going undercover to investigate the mafia in New
York.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, what about it?
It was all a big lie.
What?
What did you say?
It was really bothering me.
Why would she lie about it?
She lied.
She might be a spy.
Ridiculous.
Come on.
Even a high school student could see past it.
The head of the FBI at that time, Edgar Hoover, he was a
well-known racist.
Didn't Naomi say that her father was Japanese?
Yeah.
why would he have there wasn't a single Asian investigator
also in the 1950s the undercover mafia sting operations
hadn't even started yet they first started in 1960 in
Chicago not New York done done you better check it out the
chief and the president mysteriously dying and that ninja
too many strange things there are a lot of strange things
are you saying that Naomi might be behind it I don't No,
either that or she's working with the terrorists.
Could it be?
If I find out anything, I'll call.
In the meantime, be careful.
Master, I'm scared.
I can't trust anybody.
Wait, let's, uh...
Oh, oh, I wanted to punch that bird.
Dang it.
Ooh, it's chilly here.
It's really blue.
Campbell.
Naomi I'm right here snake what is it oh I wasn't asking I
wasn't I wasn't asking for it by now those terrorists have
finished their launch preparations stop wasting time Metal
Gear's base is up ahead snake it's over 30 below outside
what's wrong nothing thanks snake don't be so obvious snake
come on get to Metal Gear's base Round.
Snake, stop being so obvious.
Master Miller, I'm scared.
I want to ask you about Naomi.
Yeah.
I'm looking into the details now, but it doesn't look good.
Weren't you ever suspicious about her, Snake?
A lot.
I was a lot, yeah.
Snake, keep your guard up.
Master, Master, you're the only one I can trust.
What the hell are you going to do?
all these crows doing around here crows you got me there
were crows around from before but for some reason they
started to really increase in number around the same time
that foxhound came to the base maybe it's really weird i
wonder what it could mean did that just say rally weird was
that did i did I...
It's rally weird.
Nastasha, bring us off topic.
As long as the strategy of nuclear deterrence continues,
nuclear weapons may be reduced, but they will never be
eliminated.
If you think about it, nuclear reduction does not mean much
without elimination.
Nastasha, you're rally weird.
I used to work in the DI.
There she goes.
I figured the only way to achieve nuclear...
No, she's just popping off.
To work from the inside to convince them of the
ineffectiveness of the deterrence theory.
Seems like you're pretty focused on that issue.
Rally weird.
The ideas of nuclear radiation are a sad thing to see.
And I have seen a lot of it.
This is such a serious topic, too.
I have seen more than enough of it.
What do you mean?
I was born and raised in Pripyat, Ukraine.
I was 10 years old on that day.
April 26, 1986.
you don't mean yes Chernobyl Chernobyl that is the day that
changed my life didn't we watch this one or other lives I
feel like we listened to this I live just three kilometers
north of there 600,000 to 700,000 people were evacuated over
650,000 children suffered the effects of radiation poisoning
between 1986 and 1993 12,000 children died Oh my god.
My parents and many others like them who helped in the
cleanup died a few years later from radiation sickness.
We must read this world of all nuclear weapons before they
cause more misogyny.
This is a good chance to get into the stalker series.
The delicate environment that keeps us alive.
I will not allow this pain and anxiety to pass on to yet
another generation.
Wow, she sounded so serious there.
Me-Ling.
Wasn't about nuclear weapons, though.
I think it's just nuclear technology, you know.
What do you want, Snake?
If you want to talk to Naomi, why don't you call her?
Oh, no, it's fine.
Don't worry.
Don't worry about her.
Strange guy.
Why is everybody calling me strange?
Good luck, Snake.
Thank you.
Alrighty.
crows, we got all of this stuff, C4.
Giving me the C4, eh?
The Nikita missiles.
Look at my life.
I only have two out of... I only... Oh, now I have three
ration.
Three ration against Vulcan Raven?
With my... Well, really, it's gonna feel like only two
rations against Vulcan Raven.
Um...
I guess we'll see how we do next week probably I think next
is a boss fight we have a boss fight next we should actually
let's see um we have Hulk and Raven we have I figured if I
like I initially was going to endurance this.
I think if I had endurance it, I think I would have
finished.
Because all I have is Vulcan Raven and then, uh, and then
the keys and then Rex and the ending sequence.
So I think I would have actually been able to beat it if I
had actually followed through with, um, endurancing it.
But I think, um, yeah, if I went for a few more hours?
Yeah, I think so.
But I think I'm going to stop it here, and then we'll just
finish up next week, before I travel to California.
So I've been breaking her own spoiler rules.
Hey, hey.
I mean lore spoilers, okay?
Not game.
But I've already played the Twin Snakes, and so it's the
same, okay?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, guys.
Yeah, actually, I have some...
I have actually quite a bit of stuff I need to take care of.
I have a lot of recording.
We have to record the podcast since Matara forgot about a
collab she had this morning, even though I woke up on time
to record, but she completely forgot.
And so we couldn't record this morning.
Andrea goes, thanks for the 10 gifted.
And, um, so, yeah, right after this, I'm doing more talking.
And, uh, I have some other stuff I gotta do to prepare for
next week and stuff.
So, busy, busy, busy, busy.
Hi-shin, thank you.
Kochi da kuro-so.
And then next week, maybe before I go fight him, I might go
and, like, grab some rations.
Um, but I will do that off-stream.
Thanks, as always, for MGS Brandi.
rock good luck with raven next week thank you thank you
thank you guys we've made lots of lots of progress today so
um and basically almost every boss well um most fights in
one two three tries most bosses in one two three tries
try.
I know!
I know, right?
One HP in a dream, baby.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Three or less.
Spank, thank you for the 10 gift, dude.
Thank you.
Tomorrow, actually, I will be finishing Doom 64.
But also, I didn't put something on the stream, or on the
schedule of what kind of stream I will be doing.
But I will actually be debuting a chibi model that i have so
um i just kind of got it for fun because i thought it was
pretty cute um so i'll be debuting that tomorrow and um
showing you guys that and maybe i'll use it for streams and
stuff so um yeah so after the doom 64 stream i'll have i'll
have that stream for this stream.
Always a pleasure to share the MGS brain rot with you,
Minto.
Thank you!
Appreciate it.
Thank you guys so much for hanging out with me.
I appreciate you guys so much.
We're always, you know, even though it's not me for playing
for the first time and everything, but you guys all still,
you know, hang out and still, you know, still take the time
to watch me.
And I'm really appreciative.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Really happy that I can play this again and have so much
fun.
So, thank you.
And, um, there is one other thing I was going to say.
I don't remember.
It's fine, though.
Cool.
Hilbert, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Cool.
Then I'm gonna go Metal Gear next week.
Well, the continuation will actually be on Wednesday.
I have to be ready for the concert on Friday.
And I will still be at AX on Saturday.
I might do a stream when I get back on Sunday.
We'll see.
I'm not quite sure yet.
I don't remember what time I get back.
I might have gotten a red eye.
I don't quite remember.
How far did you get again?
Yeah?
Oh, we're just about to fight Vulcan Raven.
I only follow one person.
The boss.
Big boss.
You.
Me.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited for Delta.
I can't wait.
Man.
Yeah, we're really close to...
I'm turning these.
birds down i'm really we're really close to beating this so
i think on wednesday we'll definitely be able to so sorry
that it's not a metal gear saturday but i didn't want to
skip a whole week so um then the following weekend we'll
start mgs2 yippee yay yay yay i'm so hyped for delta the
more i hear about it the more i i'm hyped i know right Yeah.
Me too, honestly.
Okie dokie!
Lalilulelo.
Okay, thank you guys.
Um, I did save, right?
I did save.
Okay, I think so.
Alright.
Otsumintou!
Otsumintou, Otsumintou!
I will see you guys tomorrow.
And yeah.
Schedule for next week.
I'm almost done making it.
I have another collab with a certain bird.
Actually, I asked her because I've always wanted to play
this game with someone.
And so I asked her if she would play it with me.
I thought it would be a fun game that she and I can kind of
be really dumb with.
So actually, Doki and I will be playing Man of Madan.
because I thought that we could make really dumb choices to
kind of troll each other on each side, so
but yeah.
This is MGS number two.
It's MGS part two.
Should I change the stream title if people are getting so
confused?
But yeah, so...
Um...
I thought that would be kind of fun.
Okie dokie!
It's clear IMO.
No, we're dumb.
The title is clear!
Metal Gear Solid.
I never have had this issue before.
Maybe I used to always put that, like, hashtag, like,
hashtag 0-2.
put Metal Gear Solid No.
0-2.
But I thought having the part just made it obvious, right?
Utano!
Thank you for membership!
Oh my gosh, wait, I'm so excited for Friday!
Utano will also be at the content with me, you guys!
And she sings so beautifully.
And so we're gonna have a lot of fun!
Oh my gosh, I can't wait to meet you!
Yippee yippee Okay, maybe I won't write PT too I'll write
part two I'll just write it out Okay, anyways, I've
blabbered on enough Thank you guys, see you guys tomorrow
And, yeah Otsumito Otsumito, bye bye bye bye See you guys
later Bye bye